Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Oin Chat, und seid ihr schon wach?
Ja, offensichtlich war ihr alle wach genug, dass ihr den Stream einschalten konntet.
So viel ist schonmal sicher.
Nee, ist kein Delay drin.
Ich hatte auch gestern kein Delay.
Ich hab nur kurz überlegt, ob ich Delay reinmache, aber wer Stream sniped...
Oh, ich hab die Kategorie nicht umgestellt.
Ich muss Just Chatting machen.
Just Chatting.
Jetzt.
Ich hatte doch auf Battlefield 3 stehen.
Kegweight.
Hot Tubes und Peaches.
Stimmt, es gibt jetzt ja eine neue Kategorie auf Twitch.
Warte mal, Zeit mal her.
Da muss ich jetzt mal reingucken.
Ich mein, es kann ja kein Monka Toss sein, was auf Twitch läuft.
Wenn es Monka Toss wäre, dann würde es ja nicht auf Twitch laufen.
Sind wir uns ja einig.
Also, wo ist es denn?
IRL?
Wo gibt's denn das neue...
Wo gibt's denn die neue Kategorie?
Wo ist die denn?
Rouse.
Kategories.
Hier.
Hot.
Hot Pools.
Die haben...
Leute, Twitch hat das gemacht, was ich noch vor vier Wochen oder so gesagt habe.
Werden sie nie machen.
Ich hab vor vier Wochen gesagt, Twitch wird niemals eine eigene Kategorie einführen.
Für Pool Streams.
Und warum nicht?
Also, was meine Überlegung dahinter war, ist warum nicht?
Weil Twitch dann zugeben müsste, dass sie quasi eine Softcore Porn Kategorie bei sich
auf der Seite haben, indem man dem eine eigene Kategorie gibt.
Aber Twitch hat sich gedacht, Money regelt.
Wen juckt's?
Zeige mal her.
Was ist denn da los?
Aha.
Hot Tube Dancing.
Und Fitness Today.
Aha, alles klar.
Natürlich, ich guck diese Streams auch nur für Fitness.
Watch me dance.
Alter, warum sind diese komischen... diese Bade-Dinger da alles so in...
Na ja, gut, man könnte auch sagen in Kackwurst-Form, aber...
Ah, nice.
Gatschi.
Gatschi Pool, so muss es sein.
Guck mal, es gibt männliche Hot Tube Streamer.
Sehr gut.
Mit Fake Boobcam, alles klar.
What the fuck?
Oh, man.
Meine Güte.
Warum ist Jesus im Hot Tube?
Kein Recht.
Okay, das ist die... die verarschen den Kram.
Ja, ich mein, hallo, noch kürzer geht's nicht, ne?
Das ist ja schon quasi...
Das passt... das ist ja schon...
Das ist drei Nummer zu klein, das passt gar nicht rein.
Güte, eh.
Ach ja.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was mit Twitch los ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich mein, die sind auf der einen Seite so krass hinterher, family-friendly zu sein.
Guckt euch mal beispielsweise an, was die supporten.
Die supporten zum Beispiel GameStormQuick.
Was ich ja immer dachte, früher fand ich das richtig geiles Event.
Mittlerweile ist es mir schon zu korrekt, dass ich kaum noch gucke.
Aber da ist Twitch natürlich ganz entscheidend für mitverantwortlich.
Twitch guckt, dass das alles super family-friendly ist.
Und sobald einer mal das falsche Wort sagt, ist vorbei.
Weiß ich, ob ihr euch daran erinnern könnt.
Tryhaxe wurde letztens mal gebannt,
weil er sich beleidigt hat mit einem Freund im Teamspeak oder im TS oder im Discord.
Erst mal eine Woche gebannt, weil er das falsche Wort...
Oh, top.
Pepe please hier.
Alles klar.
Ja, wie gesagt, er wurde ja vor einer Weile gebannt, weil er das falsche Wort im Discord verwendet hat.
Also es ist anscheinend mittlerweile echt so.
Du musst deutlich mehr darauf achten, was du sagst auf Twitch,
als dich halt naggisch irgendwo hinzustellen.
Aber wie gesagt, ich finde es echt interessant, dass es da jetzt eine eigene Kategorie für gibt.
Wie gesagt, ich habe ja noch vor drei, vier Wochen gesagt, das wird es nicht geben.
Aber anscheinend hat sich Twitch gedacht, juckt mich nicht.
Money ist zu wichtig, zumal Twitch ja auch ganz viel Geld mit Subs macht.
Darf man nicht vergessen.
Ich meine, die kriegen ja von den normalen Channels die Hälfte von den Subs ab.
Also das macht schon mal richtig viel aus.
Und dieser kleiner Teil, wo die halt keine Werbung schalten oder weniger Werbung schalten,
juckt dann wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Wubcubechamps, sowas gibt es?
Wait a minute.
Was ist das?
Was sehe ich denn hier?
Warum gibt es sowas?
Warum gibt es?
Das ist ja geil.
Warum gibt es sowas?
Warte mal.
Es war 100 pro irgendeiner vom Discord.
Popular Clips, ah, passiert da auch was.
Das finde ich gut, das ist nice.
Muss man gleich auch promoten.
Ach, das Serious Max war das.
Das ist ja geil.
Auch gleich die richtigen Emotes alle aktiviert, so wie es aussieht.
Irgendwie erfüllt mich hier unten das Emote.
Ist FFZ kaputt?
Sag mal, ist FFZ kaputt?
Normalerweise sollte FFZ doch unten links so einen Button haben für den Chat.
Ja gut, interessant.
Also ich habe jetzt einen eigenen HotTube Stream ohne dass ich davon wusste.
Das ist ja schon mal gut.
Ach guck mal, es splasht auch, Alter.
Seht ihr das hier?
Das ist ja richtig High Production Value.
Ok, gut zu wissen, gleich mal speichern, zack, zumachen.
Wahnsinn, was es nicht alles gibt.
Moment, das gibt es auf, das gibt es auf, das gibt es auf GitHub?
Tatsächlich.
Guckt euch mal an, mein Pool Stream ist Open Source auf GitHub.
Seit sieben Stunden live.
Ach hier ist, hier ist das Bild.
Ok, was nicht, das müssen wir, ich kann nicht starren, Leute.
Das ist der Raid Channel, ja genau, wir hosten einfach immer den Channel, wenn es keinen anderen zum Haus gibt.
Ich bin nicht eingeloggt, ich kann nicht starren, aber wer eingeloggt ist, kann ja mal starren.
Also das ist eigentlich gerade so angesagt auf Twitch für Games.
GTA, gut, das ist zum größten halt GTA Roleplay.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal, ah gut, XQC macht einfach schon mal die Hälfte der Viewer aus.
LoL ist wieder vorne, LoL, Valorant, Valorant muss irgendwo sein, Fortnite, die üblichen Verdächtigen, Warzone, Apex.
Hier wusstet ihr eigentlich wie viel Geld Apex macht, die haben glaube ich über eine Milliarde mittlerweile verdient mit Apex.
Und ihr könnt euch mal vorstellen, Apex ist bei weitem auch nicht das größere, das größte von dieser Geschichte.
Jetzt könnt ihr euch mal überlegen, was die mit Fortnite verdienen.
Oder zumindest was die am Anfang mit PUBG verdient haben, mittlerweile spielt ja irgendwie keiner PUBG, aber am Anfang zumindest.
Die haben krass viel Geld verdient mit Apex, Fortnite hatte wahrscheinlich 10x, die haben wahrscheinlich 50 Milliarden oder was auch immer.
Ja, PUBG spielt keiner mehr, wo ist das überhaupt?
Guck mal, die spielen sogar Free Fire, was zum Teufel ist Free Fire?
Keine Ahnung, hab ich nicht gehört, wo ist denn Player?
Wo ist denn Unknown?
Wo ist es denn, du bist jetzt gar nicht mehr dabei? PUBG, PUBG ist weg.
Guck mal, das normale Court spielt kein Mensch.
Wo ist es denn? Ach da, da ist es, ja PUBG. Warum? Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum ich das nicht mehr erkenne.
Warum sieht denn das aus wie Rainbow Six?
Warum sieht denn das Cover aus wie Rainbow Six? Jetzt hatten die früher nicht so ein anderes Cover.
So ein...
So ein... Anderes Cover, so ein bunteres Cover. Die hatten doch vorher ein anderes Cover. Hier, das da hatten die früher. Das hat man wenigstens auch erkannt.
Also mal ganz im Ernst, dieses Cover hat man viel einfacher gefunden als das, was ich hier gesehen habe.
Also mal ganz im Ernst, dieses Cover hat man viel einfacher gefunden als das, was ich hier gesehen habe. Die hatten doch vorher ein anderes Cover. Hier, das da hatten die früher. Das hat man wenigstens auch erkannt.
Also mal ganz im Ernst, dieses Cover hat man viel einfacher gefunden als das da. Das sieht doch aus wie ein neuer Rainbow Six Siege Operator, der Dude.
Wie laut vielleicht, ich mach einen ganz kleinen Tick leiser.
Na gut.
Food and Drink, was gibt's denn hier? Ihr seht, ich bin...
What the fuck, was ist das?
Ist das irgendwas, irgendeine Qualle oder so?
Eine Rinderzunge. Ach steht ja auch da, guck mal da. Rinderzunge steht ja direkt drauf.
Dann seht ihr mal, ich lese mittlerweile schon Text auf Bildern gar nicht mehr.
Food Shows.
Okay, auf Twitch gibt's anscheinend mittlerweile alles. Also wisst ihr was ich lustig finde?
Ja, wisst ihr was ich lustig finde? Erst gab es Justintv. Und Justintv war ja mehr oder weniger sowas hier. Also so Kram.
Und dann haben die gesagt, Justintv ist irgendwie nicht so das, wir machen TwitchTV und stellen Justintv nach einer Weile ein. Und jetzt entwickelt sich Twitch wieder zu Justintv.
Justintv.
Tja.
Dass sich alles gibt. Na gut. Wie dem auch sei.
Die haben die Wubblers recommended. Ja, Twitch ist ja nicht doof. Twitch kapiert halt welchen Channel wir öfters aufmachen.
Was ist das da unten für ein Overlay?
Hä? Eben ist es wieder weg.
Jetzt spiegeln wir uns, Chat. Wubbleek.
Übrigens, Chat, wisst ihr was ich gestern ausprobiert hab? Ich hab gestern ausprobiert.
VCFace.
Das ist ein Programm, wo man mit seinem iPhone oder einer Webcam kann man ein Anime Grill sein.
Warte mal, ich zeige euch mal das Bild. Warte mal, ich zeige euch mal das Bild, weil wir kurz ausmachen, weil ich nicht weiß, in welchem Channel ich war.
Wartet mal.
Gleich, gleich wieder da. Gleich wieder da.
Muss kurz Discord aufmachen, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, in welchem Channel ich gewesen bin.
So, ähm, ja. Ich schau wieder an.
Cute Chat. Lul, was wird hier für Zeug gepostet? Guck mal, ich war gestern an einem Anime Grill.
Ich gestern ausprobiert mit der Webcam und dem iPhone. Das ist gar nicht so einfach, sag ich euch.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach. Man muss auf dem iPhone eine App installieren.
Das war das, also warum ich dieses Model genommen hab ist, das ist das einzige was Zusatzelemente hat, dass das mit der iPhone-Kamera funktioniert.
So, also man muss, man braucht irgendwie, so man braucht irgendwie dieses Programm, das macht Motion Tracking.
Und das kann man, dann kann man auf dem iPhone noch eine Zusatz-App installieren.
Die sendet dann Motion Track, also von Face ID, von der Kamera sendet das Motion noch hier in das Programm.
Das heißt, ich konnte sogar nur mit dem linken Auge pinseln und es hat es erkannt. Das war eigentlich ziemlich nice.
Gut, ich mein ich werd jetzt nicht als Anime Grill streamen.
Die erste Reaktion, ja genau das dachte ich mir an eurer Stelle auch gedacht.
Ich hab ja sogar mitgeweertchamped. Jetzt brauch ich nur noch irgendeinen Fiverr, Fiverr Inder, der mir einen Keks baut.
So, so wie Tuber 3D, wie Tuber 3D, wer erstellt da Dinger?
Die erstellen alle nur irgendwelche, die erstellen alle nur irgendwelche menschlich aussehende Avatar.
Aber ich brauch einen Keks. Ich brauch einen Keks. Wen soll ich ansprechen auf Twitch? Muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Muss ich mir mal merken.
Ja, also guck, die erstellen nur so komische, so Avatare. Ich hab mich in der Arme gemerkt, Piek.
Stimmt, wo ist die Katze hin? Die Katze hab ich ausgeplendet. Nein, das war das Falsche. Auch Falsche.
Ah, hier ist die Katze.
Die bauen alle nur so komische an. Ich brauch jemand, der richtige 3D Models macht und dementsprechend auch einen...
Ich mein, das sieht alles schon fast illegal aus, was ich hier sehe.
3D Model. Irgendeiner noch?
Der 3D Models macht. Und keine, keine 12-jährigen Anime-Grills.
Guckt euch das mal an. Ist ja einschlimmer. Was heißt schlimmer? Ist ja einschlimmer als das andere.
Character Modeling, komm.
Character Modeling, können wir mal gucken.
Guck mal, ich brauch irgendjemand, der normale 3D Models macht.
Normale 3D Models. Keine, keine Anime-Grills mit so einem vorgefertigten Programm. Normale 3D Models, weil der muss mir den Keks machen.
Alter, die werden ja immer jünger. Monkeys.
Guck mal, der Typ zum Beispiel. Das sieht doch schon mal ganz gut aus.
Eine Runde an Nele-Model. Guck mal. Der kann doch bestimmt sowas hier.
Sowas in der Richtung, genau. Da siehst du, dass der Typ schon mal ein bisschen was kann.
70 Euro ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Du hast Zeit gehabt, zeig mal her.
Neues E-Mode.
Oh, wir haben jetzt sogar Woop Arrive. Das muss ich reinmachen gleich, Leute.
Wir haben Woop Leave und Woop Arrive jetzt gleich. Das muss rein.
Pock. Der Chainlord hat zugeschlagen. Add Woop Arrive ist geadded.
70 Euro ist nicht teuer. Nee, ist es nicht. Was heißt ich benutze... Nee, wenn das ein gutes Model ist, benutze ich das auch öfters als einmal.
Also der Typ weiß ja anscheinend schon mal so ungefähr alles, was er macht. Und ich glaube, so einen Keks, ich meine mal ernsthaft,
so einen Keks nachzubauen in 3D stelle ich mir jetzt... Ich habe da zwar... What the fuck.
Das bin ich übrigens, by the way. Ich weiß auch nicht, wo das hinkommt.
Ich stelle es mir jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig kompliziert vor, einen 3D Model Keks zu machen.
Was ich mir schwieriger vorstelle ist, der Keks muss ja insofern auch ein Skelett bekommen.
Also sprich, dass ich die Hände bewegen kann und dass sich die Augen und der Mund bewegt.
Also das ist dann ein bisschen schwieriger und das kostet wahrscheinlich auch mehr.
Genau. Da kostet es bei dem.
Ich brauche Rigging.
Compare Packages. Ah, hier guck mal. Standard.
Ich brauche Rigging. Das kostet 215 Euro. Easy.
Rigging ist das, dass du auch Knochen und Gelenke und so da reinbaust.
Und das brauchst du, dass er die Hände bewegen kann.
Glaube ich zumindest.
Nee, nee, das ist nicht dabei. Guck, hier ist der Haken grau, hier ist der Haken grau und hier ist der Haken grün.
Glaube ich zumindest, dass er uns das damit sagen will, oder?
Oder was soll es das andere sagen?
Was letzte Preis?
He was great. Great 3D Modeller.
Ich glaube, das ist etwas missverständlich mit dem grünen Häkchen.
Ich glaube, der möchte einfach nur sagen, nochmal explizit, dass es nicht dabei ist.
Dann wäre es besser gewesen, anstatt dem grünen Haken ehrlich gesagt an den X hin zu machen.
Oder es ist Fiverr Vorgabe oder sowas.
Romulo Dovale.
Ja, so Leute könnte man da mal anschreiben.
Und ich glaube, es ist nicht so krass schwierig, den Keks zu machen in 3D.
Lieber nach Indian Outsourcen. Ich habe hier nichts gefunden.
Ich finde hier nur welche, die viel zu junge Animegrills machen.
Und ich habe Angst, wenn ich weiter klicke, dass gleich irgendwelche Not Safe for Work Bilder kommen.
Ernsthaft?
Stunning 3D.
Erstmal Uganda Knuckles.
Und wahnsinnig hoch aufgelöst.
Sieht äußerst vielversprechend aus.
Also da werde ich natürlich für 43 Euro ganz bestimmt bestellen.
Ja, ich werde mir irgendwie so 3D Modeller, 3D Modeller Leute raussuchen.
Ich bezahle den. Also ich habe da keine Schmerzen mit.
Ich finde das durchaus angemessen. Der braucht ja auch eine Weile für.
Aber es muss halt auch gut werden für den Preis da.
Oder schon was Scheiß rauskommen.
Exzellent.
So.
Mal refreshen, was uns YouTube empfiehlt.
Semper Video. Pyhole Blocksite Configure Kit. Das interessiert mich nicht.
Black Ops Added Callable Nukes. Ernsthaft?
Haben die sowas jetzt?
Du-Düt. Du-Düt. Du-Düt.
Ach anscheinend. Guck mal da.
Ne.
Oder auch nicht.
Ich finde die 200 Euro auch absolut gerechtfertigt.
Also wenn der da auch jetzt genauer drauf eingeht, was Sache ist ja.
Und mich da ein paar Sachen fragt und das genau nach meinen Vorstellungen macht.
Habe ich auch keine Schmerzen mit da ein bisschen mehr zu bezahlen.
Da war gerade ein Video. How to uninstall Warzone on someones PC.
Ja das ist einfach. Das kenne ich das Video.
Der bringt den zum Ragequitten.
Ok. Gibt's? YouTube empfiehlst du uns irgendwas spannendes?
Ansonsten gucke ich das was ich. Seit Dezember kein Präsenzunterricht.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft. Ich versuche mich da mal rein zu versetzen.
Also wenn ich in die Schule gehen würde.
Ich glaube mir wäre Unterricht daheim am Computer viel lieber als in die Schule zu gehen.
Ich meine. Ich bin damals auch schon lieber vor dem Rechner sitzen geblieben und habe 24-7 was gegrindet.
Ich meine nicht die ganze Zeit ja. Aber ab und zu mal ein paar Tage die Woche ist es doch nice.
Online ist kacke. Warum? Warum ist online kacke?
Du lernst nix. Die Frage ist hättest du was gelernt wenn du vor Ort fährst.
Ich glaube das Problem an Online Unterricht das da so scheiße ist liegt zum größten Teil daran.
Dass es Lehrer braucht die Ahnung von der Technik haben. Dass es Technik an sich braucht.
Dass es eine gute Infrastruktur, Plattform, Basis dafür braucht.
Weil in der Theorie hier würde ich sagen ist doch Home Unterricht richtig geil.
Ja aber das ist doch nicht das Problem von Homeschooling sondern das Problem von dem wie es gemacht wird.
Das ist doch das Problem wie es gemacht wird.
Also das ist wenn man sagt okay so wie wir es jetzt machen ist es scheiße und funktioniert nicht.
Okay das verstehe ich. Aber von der Idee her ist Online Unterricht doch eigentlich eine super Geschichte.
Ich meine man muss das jetzt nicht die ganze Woche über machen.
Aber zum Beispiel könnten so Eltern auch in Urlaub fahren und die Kinder würden einfach vormittags sich mit dem Laptop mal irgendwie eine Woche oder so.
Da morgens sich das angucken und gut ist.
Dann müssten sich alle in den Sommerferien immer zusammen sich in den Flieger pressen.
Also ich denke Online Unterricht ist eines der besten Sachen die man machen kann.
Aber nicht in der Art und Weise wie wir es gerade machen.
Ja die kann man doch haben. Man kann doch auch in Online Spielen soziale Kontakte haben.
Das heißt ja nicht dass du gar nicht mehr in die Schule musst.
Aber man könnte durchaus sagen okay wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel den Freitag.
Freitag ist Homeschooling. Da sind die Leute gleich daheim.
Also das kann man machen. Ich bin ja auch der Meinung dass Homeoffice in vielen Bereichen möglich ist wo es jetzt immer gesagt wird es geht nicht.
Zum Beispiel auch im Handwerkerbereich ist Homeoffice denke ich wenn alle Seiten wollen möglich.
Teilweise nicht permanent zum Beispiel wenn die irgendwelchen Papierkram machen müssen oder irgendwelche Fortbildung, Schulung machen müssen oder irgendwelche Rechnungen schreiben.
Keine Ahnung für Sachen wo du nicht vor Ort sein musst.
Deswegen kann ich mir das gut vorstellen dass auch keine Ahnung ihr sogar Maler und Handwerker durchaus mal ein paar Tage Homeoffice im Monat machen können.
Wenn das alle Beteiligten wollen sich daran gewöhnen.
Das Problem ist eher das hier einmal dass unsere Infrastruktur so schlecht ist und dass die Leute in Deutschland im Kopf nicht in der Lage sind sich auszumalen wie sowas aussehen könnte und wie sowas funktionieren könnte.
Das ist glaube ich das hauptsächliche Problem.
Die Leute sagen aha so wie es jetzt ist funktioniert das nicht und deswegen ist das schlecht.
Aber anstatt sich einfach mal Gedanken darüber zu machen ok was könnte man dann machen und ich denke da ist doch da ist eigentlich sowohl Homeoffice als auch dass man Schule von daheim besuchen kann jetzt vielleicht nicht das ganze Jahr aber auch nicht die ganze Woche über.
Eines der wirklich zukunftsweisenden Sachen.
So wird das ja das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Also deswegen das ist einfach nur so ein Ding weil es bei vielen Leuten im Kopf funktioniert das nicht. Viele Leute sind zu unkreativ sich da mal ein bisschen weiter zu denken. Also es ist ja oft so wenn man eine Sache macht und die klappt nicht dann sagen die Leute ich hab doch gleich gesagt das ist scheiße.
Das ist nicht gesagt dass die Idee scheiße ist sondern vielleicht ist einfach nur die Umsetzung wie sie jetzt gerade ist scheiße. Es gibt ja viele Sachen da ist die Idee gut aber die Umsetzung kacke.
Zum Beispiel die Idee mit Uploadfiltern an sich ist ja gar nicht so doof. Die Umsetzung ist einfach total beschissen.
Und auch die ganzen Unsicherheiten die drum herum entstehen.
Stell dir mal vor Schule in VR. Ja so Dinge zum Beispiel genau da muss man einfach sich ein bisschen was überlegen ein bisschen was vorstellen können.
Das wäre auf jeden Fall cool.
Dass wir nicht dass wir nicht von wir machen Schule und jetzt machen wir 100% VR Schule springen können ist auch klar.
Übrigens was ist das hier wieder exquisite Musik im Hintergrund hier.
Was ist das das Mario Galaxy ist weil ich eine Mario Galaxy Playlist angemacht habe.
Genau man müsste sich einfach überlegen wie macht man das und dann braucht man ja auch ein paar Anläufe bis es funktioniert.
Genau das meine ich ja das das meine ich dadurch dass man vielleicht eine gute Idee hat die aber beschissen umgesetzt wird sagen die Leute das ist kacke.
Ich meine guckt euch mal so ziemlich alle IT Projekte an die die Deutschland gemacht hat. Von der Gesundheitskarte bis zum Personalausweis und was es nicht noch alles gibt.
Alles von der Idee her gar nicht so doof aber die Umsetzung einfach kacke.
Hatten wir eigentlich irgendein IT Projekt was wirklich mal erfolgreich gut funktioniert hat die letzten Jahre über.
Was macht denn der was macht eigentlich der EU Impfout der der elektronische EU Impfausweis.
Ist der ist er mittlerweile.
Noch nicht umgesetzt das ist geil wenn es jetzt noch nicht umgesetzt sind glaube ich schon 15 oder 20% der Leute geimpft.
Warum gibt es jetzt nicht die Corona Warn App ja gut die Corona Warn App hat ganz gut funktioniert aber auch zum größten Teil.
Weil es nicht Leute gemacht haben die es sonst machen.
Die Corona Warn App man hat nur funktioniert und auch mit ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten weil man extrem viel Geld in die Hand genommen hat.
Und irgendwelche Telekom SAP Leute da dran gesetzt hat oder Oracle ne SAP. Also dass die sowas machen können wissen wir.
Aber unsere normalen IT Projekte sind halt in der Regel ziemlich fail. Die dauern teilweise so lang.
Also wir haben ja eh einen Hang dazu guck dir ist wie sieht es eigentlich aus weil hat jemand noch News von Stuttgart 21.
Was ist da so eigentlich ist das ich meine wir haben 2021 ist das nicht.
Läuft das läuft das.
Was ist da.
Stimmt der Flughafen in Berlin ist fertig was ich halt ein bisschen merkwürdig finde ist dass das Flughafen in Berlin.
Stimmt der Flughafen in Berlin ist fertig was ich halt ein bisschen merkwürdig finde ist dass das mittlerweile so akzeptiert ist.
Also es ist ja es ist ja so fast jedes Bauprojekt was ein bisschen größer ist.
Und darüber berichtet wird wird nicht darüber berichtet weil es jetzt neu und geil ist.
Sondern weil es Verspätung hat und mehr kostet und man keine Ahnung hat was fertig wird oder.
Weil der Veranstalter irgendwie seinem seinem Stiefvater da seiner Firma den Auftrag gegeben hat obwohl er nicht durfte oder sonst was.
Und deswegen kommen die Sachen in den Nachrichten aber nicht weil sie fertig sind.
Und was ich ein bisschen doof finde ist dass wir uns alle schon so damit abgefunden haben.
Also jener lacht nur noch drüber Deutschland stellt ihnen ein IT Projekt vor und jeder einfach nur noch.
Das wird doch eh nix das klappt nicht das Schlimme ist dass es ist ja auch so das klappt ja auch in der Regel nicht.
Und das ist ja berechtigt dass man da drüber lacht.
Aber ich finde es doof dass man sich da schon so komplett damit abgefunden hat und sich denkt so wir können es halt nicht besser.
Naja wir können es ja anscheinend auch nicht besser aber das heißt nicht dass man nicht was dran ändern könnte dass man es besser kann.
Genauso wie unser Gelaber immer zum Internet ausbauen bis 2010 bis 2011 bis 2015 bis 2000.
Ich glaube jetzt haben sie letztens erzählt bis 2030 und wisst ihr was das geile ist letztens habe ich gelesen.
Dass Deutschland führend digital beim digitalen Amt werden soll und genau hier hier.
Das ist schon von 2017 passen wir auf bis 2021 ist Deutschlands Verwaltung komplett digital.
Das ist eines der großen Probleme die wir haben.
Die es weltweit gibt dass einfach Sachen gesagt werden komplett aus dem Zusammenhang also einfach nur einfach nur gesagt um es zu sagen.
Weil es gut klingt und man hat sich einfach 2017 gedacht alle das sind noch vier Jahre bis wir das machen.
Da erinnert sich doch eh keine Sau mehr dran dass ich das gesagt habe.
Übrigens die Typen sind immer noch in der Regierung man müsste ja mal konnten wir ja mal fragen so nach dem Motto warum ist das nicht passiert.
Die geilste Ausrede ist ja immer noch die ich in letzter Zeit gehört habe wenn du fragst.
Wenn du fragst so hier warum habt ihr denn nicht gemacht was ihr versprochen habt.
Die beste Ausrede die ich in letzter Zeit gehört habe ist ja weil uns nicht genug Leute gewählt haben.
Ist es nicht eigentlich umgedreht man zeigt dass man das macht was man sagt und dann wählen ein mehr Leute.
Also ist das nicht irgendwie falsch rum.
Also zum Beispiel in Hessen wir haben einen grünen Umweltminister und bei uns sind die Grünen auch schon länger am Start.
Und die sind damals im Wald das kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Die sind damals angetreten und haben gesagt Frankfurter Flughafen wird nicht ausgebaut es gibt keine neue Startbahn es gibt kein neues Terminal und noch so ein paar Dinge.
So und nichts gar nichts von dem was sie damals im Wahlkampf erzählt haben haben sie gemacht.
So und letztens wurden sie gefragt in einem Interview ja sagen sie mal was ist eigentlich aus ihren letzten Wahlversprechen geworden davon wurde ja nichts umgesetzt.
Oder war die Antwort ja wir konnten nicht weil uns nicht genug Leute gewählt haben.
Ja was was was ist das für eine bescheuerte Begründung hätten die 90% hätten sie 90% gewollt oder was.
Dass sie dann wie in China die Bagger hätten anrollen lassen können mit ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste oder wie.
Was ist das für eine bescheuerte Begründung.
Da haben sie sich nicht genug gewählt soll es nicht eher umgedreht sein.
Man sagt was man macht was und dann sehen die Leute okay der sagt was er macht was er sagt und dann.
Das wird eh noch lustig das wird eh noch lustig.
2021 also hier Ende 2021 bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl.
Das wird noch witziger.
Ich gehe dann auch ich gehe auch nach wo muss man aktuell hin auswandern.
Dubai sind auch die ganzen Influencer.
Ich will nicht nach Dubai Dubai sagt richtig mega Alter.
Arnele land.
Madeira da weiß ich nur das Unge auf Madeira ist.
Wie sind so die Steuern in Madeira die nehmen bestimmt die nehmen bestimmt erst Leute ab 100.000 plus im Monat oder so.
Wobei 100.000 plus im Monat easy easy man ich brauche einfach mehr Subs.
Die Schweiz in der Schweiz ist alles so teuer.
Oh man.
Na gut ja aber da bin ich was sagen eigentlich so was sagen eigentlich ich muss mal kurz was gucken.
Was sagen eigentlich so gerade die Umfragen ich will einfach nur mal schnell schnell reingucken Wikipedia hat er immer halbwegs aktuelle Sachen.
Was sagen denn so die aktuellen Umfragen schreibt mal her.
Ja ja was Katar.
Ach nee Kanta Katar ist wieder was anderes.
Also aktuell ist so halbe halbe die Hälfte der Umfrage sagen CDU und die Hälfte der Umfrage sagen Grüne.
Was hatten die SPD so die FDP so also okay immer schwankt schwankt immer.
Ja ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich tendiere aktuell zur FDP.
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt keinen so wirklich wählen will.
Ja mal gucken.
Nicht SPD FDP FDP SPD wähle ich ganz bestimmt nicht.
Ich hätte Video für dich Bock zum Thema Digitalisierung Deutschland ja schick mal wenn es nicht wenn es nicht so nicht nicht nicht zu lang ist.
Ich kann halt keinen so ich will eigentlich ich will eigentlich will ich keinen so wirklich davon wählen wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ich bin ja jemand ich also rein für mich persönlich ich setze ja da auch schon einiges um bei mir.
Und ich hätte auch wenn ich viel Autofahr ich hätte ich hätte inziden Elektroauto.
Ich bin auch gerade am gucken wie es mit Solar aussieht und alles also ich bin ja jemand der ist Umweltschutz an sich nicht abgeneigt.
Aber ich kann um es verrein nicht die Grünen wählen ich habe mir letztens ich war letztens bei den Grünen auf der Homepage.
Und hat mir mal angeguckt was die vorschlagen und das erste was ich gesehen habe ist ich soll mehr Steuern bezahlen und wenn ich irgendwelche Finanz.
Wie nennt man das gewinne gewinne am Finanzmarkt mache soll ich auch noch mehr Geld bezahlen habe ich mir gedacht okay also jetzt mal jetzt mal jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Also gerade die Leute die ihr Leben eh schon zu 90 Prozent der Arbeit widmen sollen mehr Geld bezahlen.
Okay ich sage ja nicht dass man nicht Familien auch mehr Geld lassen sollte das ist ja ein ganz anderes Thema.
Aber auch wenn ich wenn ich jetzt Kapital erträge aber auch wenn ich jetzt Geld verdiene mit sagen wir mit Aktien oder so.
Dann wollen sie nicht 25 Prozent drauf sondern das was ich als normalen Satz für die Einkommenssteuer habe.
Ich meine was soll das denn wenn ich jetzt das Risiko auf mich nehme und Aktien kaufe und ich gewinne damit mache.
Dann ist es doch vollkommen okay dass ich auch einen großen Teil davon bekomme.
Ich meine ich habe das Risiko alle anderen nicht.
Warum soll warum soll ich dann warum soll ich dann die Hälfte abgeben für Risikofrei Money.
Wenn ich Minus mache bleibe ich komplett drauf sitzen die Logik verstehe ich nicht.
Vielleicht kann ich mir irgendjemand erklären aber ich darf es nicht so genau wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich muss euch mal also deswegen kann ich mir das nicht geben.
Der Umweltschutz Part den finde ich super da habe ich überhaupt keine überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit.
Das ist nicht das warte mal warum sieht denn die Seite so kacke aus.
Das ist nicht das was ich letztens hatte.
Wofür stehen die Grün das hatte ich letztens glaube ich.
Was hatte ich denn ich hatte letztens relativ gute Übersicht finde ich jetzt aber ist auch egal.
Wo war das denn ich hatte letztens richtig gute Übersicht von denen auf ihrer Seite.
Wo dann so Sachen drinne standen wie Single Haushalte.
Single Haushalte wo was drinne stand von Single Haushalte ab 100.000 Euro und Zeugs.
Ich finde das nicht mehr.
Hier war das nicht das.
Ne das war was viel kürzeres oder vielleicht gibt es diese unten.
Das war das nicht.
Wo habe ich das denn letztens gefunden.
Ich bin ich finde es nicht mehr.
Ach das hier das hier oder genau genau das das hier meine ich also genau das ist das hier unten.
Thema Steuern oder ist es das.
Ja das ist das ist glaube ich so die Essenz die Essenz des ganzen.
Also das erste ist was mir schon mal auf den Keks geht wie gesagt gegen Umweltschutz Geschichten sage ich überhaupt nichts.
Was das erste was mir schon mal persönlich echt auf den Keks geht ist.
Anhebung des Spitzensteuersatzes für Single Einkommen ab 100.000 Euro.
Ich meine wird man jetzt ernsthaft dafür bestraft dass man schon den ganzen Tag nichts anderes macht als arbeiten.
Ich meine in der Regel jemand der einen Single Haushalt ab 100.000 Euro.
Das sind entweder Leute die haben einfach viel geerbt okay.
Aber die meisten die das haben und 100.000 Euro ist wenn man 24 7 Karriere crime macht durchaus kein Ding.
Aber so ein richtig ehrgeiziger Typ ist der auch in der passenden Branche ist.
Also jemand der quasi eh schon 24 7 arbeitet soll jetzt extra noch mehr bezahlen oder was.
Warum?
Einkommen nicht Einkünfte ja okay was was meinen sie denn damit wenn ich ab 100.000 Euro verdiene.
Single Einkommen heißt doch wenn ich nicht verheiratet bin und 100.000 Euro im Jahr verdiene.
Also vorsteuern noch höchstwahrscheinlich natürlich sonst wäre es ja langweilig es geht ja hier ums Versteuern.
Also wenn du Einkommen ist nach Anrechnung Krankenkasse Rentenversicherung.
Aber wie wollen sie das dann rechnen wenn es darum geht ob das die Grundlage ist für ob du besteuert wirst oder nicht.
Hä?
Okay okay Einkommen versus Einkünfte.
Aha das Einkommen ist der Gesamtbetrag der Einkünfte abzüglich Sonneausgaben außergewöhnlichen Belastung Verlust.
Ja gut du kannst ein Job Ticket davon absetzen das kannst du ja jetzt auch schon.
Du kannst ja jetzt auch schon wenn du wenn du irgendwie super teuer zum Arzt gegangen bist dein Auto kaputt gegangen ist was du für einen Job brauchst das kannst du jetzt ja auch schon machen.
Aber trotzdem generell mehr Steuern bezahlen sehe ich nicht ein können mich mal.
Man könnte ja auch einfach sagen okay also man hebt nicht den Spitzensteuersatz an sondern was mir persönlich viel lieber wäre.
Man sorgt dafür dass man nicht schon Apel und ein Ei ums jetzt mal übertrieben zu sagen Spitzensteuersatz bezahlen muss.
Ich sehe es nämlich überhaupt nicht ein wenn jemand okay wenn jemand wirklich reich ist dass der Spitzensteuersatz bezahlt ist ja vollkommen in Ordnung.
Chainlow du hast die Katze.
Oh die ist gut.
Wann ist jemand reich wenn er zwei goldene BMWs hat ist er reich easy.
Aber alles alles was nach mehr Steuern sieht und ganz im Ernst ich meine ich bin ich bin nicht bei 100.000 Euro im Jahr.
Aber wenn ich noch ein bisschen man darf nicht vergessen die Gehälter steigen ja auch wenn ich noch ein bisschen mehr auf der Arbeit verdiene.
Und wenn ich noch ein bisschen mehr YouTube Sellout mache also ich bin jetzt da im Prinzip auch nicht so ultra weit von weg dass ich sagen könnte da komme ich nicht hin.
Also wenn ich mich wirklich anstrengen würde wenn ich mich wirklich anstrengen würde und auch voll Sellout machen und alles auf YouTube und auch ein bisschen mehr und sonst wie dann wäre das durchaus drin.
Und das sehe ich nicht ein dass ich dann noch mehr bezahlen muss also ich streng mich mehr an und mache mehr und deswegen soll ich dann auch mehr bezahlen oder was ne das sehe ich nicht ein.
Das sehe ich nicht ein.
Weird Flex ja meinetwegen ihr wisst doch was ich verdiene das kann sich doch jeder überlegen ich hab es euch doch schon gezeigt.
Übrigens ich hab meinen Chef gefragt ich darf es euch jetzt zeigen.
Ich hab meinen ich hab meinen ähm meinen Chef gefragt ob ich euch erzählen darf was ich verdiene.
Und hat gemeint ja darf ich ist nicht verboten deswegen Gehaltsreveal da mach ich auch noch mal ein Video drüber.
So also das habe ich euch ja schon mal gezeigt weil die Frage kommt ja auch immer wieder das habe ich euch schon mal gezeigt also gültig ab 1. Juni 2021.
Ist das hier so das mal 14 ist die Basicsache aus dem Tarifvertrag dazu kommt noch also wie nennt sich das erfolgsabhängiger Bonus oder sowas.
Also sprich das wird das wird dann noch also das Jahresgeld wird dann noch auf aufgestockt durch ich glaube um 0,8 Monatsgehälter wenn irgendwie irgendwelche Ziele erreicht wurden oder so fragt mich nicht.
Keine Ahnung wie das genau läuft ist aber jedes Jahr der Fall deswegen kann man das dabei rechnen.
Dann krieg ich demnächst noch so bisschen mehr Geld und ich krieg noch nen Bonus oben drauf.
Das heißt alles in allem zusammen ich sag euch jetzt einfach mal wie es ist sind das aufgerundet aufgerundet.
Einfach aufgerundet ein bisschen also ein bisschen aufgerundet und ein glatter Betrag sind das ungefähr für 5 Tage 70.000 Euro im Jahr für 5 Tage.
So und das ganze muss man mal 0,8 rechnen weil ich arbeite ja nur 4 Tage.
Dann verdiene ich 56.000 Euro im Jahr Brutto nur von der Arbeit.
Dazu kommt jetzt dass ich noch YouTube-Stells mache und Twitch und wenn wir mal davon ausgehen dass ich aktuell um die 300 Subs auf Twitch hab.
Dass ich noch viel viel mehr Sellout machen könnte auf YouTube mit YouTube-Kanalmitgliedschaften irgendwelchen Sponsorings oder sonst was.
Dann ist das nicht so weit hin gedacht dass ich ungefähr mit YouTube und Twitch nochmal ungefähr das hier verdiene was ich auf der Arbeit krieg.
Und dann bin ich über 100.000 und das seh ich nicht ein und ich komm nur über 100.000 weil ich halt fett mich anstrenge dafür.
Und warum soll ich dann wenn ich mich noch fett für angestrengt hab bestraft werden um nochmal mehr zu bezahlen als jetzt schon.
Seh ich nicht.
Seh ich nicht ein.
2,5 von einem Sub.
Aber ich könnte ja noch deutlich mehr Sellout machen, ich könnte YouTube-Kanalmitgliedschaften machen, ich könnte mehr Rafflings machen.
Es gibt zig Varianten die ich nicht mache die ich machen könnte und mal angenommen ich würde wirklich sagen hey ich mach jetzt hier voll den YouTube-Money-Grind.
Dann ist das was ich damit sagen will ist halt das ist keine wahnsinnig riesenhohe Grenze.
Und man darf ja nicht vergessen wenn ich das wirklich machen würde das würde ja natürlich auch viel Zeit in Anspruch nehmen.
Das heißt ich würde 4 Tage die Woche arbeiten plus nochmal quasi die vielleicht ist nicht die gleiche Zeit und ich seh das ja hier mit Twitch und YouTube auch nicht wirklich als Arbeit an.
Aber wenn man es mal als Arbeit sieht allein schon aus dem Grund weil ich damit Geld verdiene dann brauch ich nochmal dann arbeite ich quasi acht Tage die Woche.
Also jeweils acht Stunden wenn du so willst acht Tage die Woche acht Tage in sieben Tage arbeite ich dann um dahin zu kommen.
Und dafür soll ich bestraft werden dass ich das mache. Nö sehe ich nicht ein deswegen können die mich mal.
Und ich sage ja nicht dass das hier der Weisheitsletzter Schluss ist also gerade Pflegehandwerker man darf das ja nicht gegeneinander ausspielen.
Selbstverständlich sollen die auch mehr verdienen.
Das heißt ja nicht nur weil ich jetzt sage hey da gibt es ordentlich was sollen andere nicht auch mehr verdienen da habe ich überhaupt kein Problem mit.
Wenn es nach mir geht dürften gerade Altenpfleger Leute die im Krankenhaus arbeiten und sonst was die können dir das doppelte bezahlen.
Da hätte ich überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit weil das sind wichtige Jobs und nicht nur da gibt ja was weiß ich auch bei der beim Straßenbau und bei der Müllabfuhr und sonstige Sachen.
Also da wo man auch sieht dass Leute viel krank sind sind ja in der Regel auch die Jobs die große Belastung haben.
Denen können die meinetwegen alle das doppelte bezahlen.
Dann wären wenigstens meine Steuern sinnvoll irgendwie investiert.
Aber das größte Problem was ich damit habe mit mehr Steuern zu bezahlen ist dass ich nicht den Eindruck habe dass meine Steuern dort verwendet werden in Bereichen wo es mir wichtig ist.
Zum Beispiel Internetinfrastrukturausbau oder dass unser Krankenhaus wie nennt man das Krankenkassen und Gesundheitssystem quasi immer mehr darauf rausläuft dass Patienten einfach nur irgendwelche Zahlen in BWL Rechnungen sind.
Und das sind so Sachen wo ich mir denke das war tatsächlich früher, ich will nicht sagen dass früher alles besser war, war es garantiert nicht, das war aber früher besser.
Wo soll das Geld herkommen? Naja wir sind die viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt.
Also wenn wir nicht das Geld haben dann hat es keiner und wir leben maßlos über das was wir haben was ja aber wiederum nicht sein kann.
Weil es gerade im Bereich Infrastruktur und Gesundheitssystem schon mal deutlich besser funktioniert hat.
Das Geld wird wahrscheinlich einfach nur für zu viel Schwachsinn ausgegeben.
Die CDU, FDP wird da auch kein Geld in Infrastruktur, das ist ja das Problem deswegen weiß ich auch nicht wen ich wählen soll.
Aber wenn ich die Auswahl habe zwischen welchen die im Parteiprogramm oder im Wahlprogramm schon schreiben ich soll mehr Steuern bezahlen und welchen das nicht.
Da wähle ich lieber die die das nicht wollen. 4G Ausbau oder ich wähle die Partei.
Also was ich finde übrigens auch nicht alle schlecht bei denen, was ich zum Beispiel ganz gut finde ist der zweite Punkt.
Steuervermeidung und Steuerbetrug bekämpfen das finde ich vollkommen in Ordnung.
Wenn Amazon in Luxemburg am Start ist oder Apple in Irland oder hast du nicht gesehen da finde ich das bescheuert dass die kein Steuer bezahlen müssen klar.
Das ist eine Sache das finde ich gut aber das erste ist das was mich abschreckt das finde ich nicht gut.
Ich werde nicht die Partei wählen nein nein ich werde auf jeden Fall irgendeinen hiervon wählen weil das ansonsten ja verschenkt ist.
Also wenn du eine kleine Partei wählst oder nicht wählst dann ist es ja rechnerisch so dass deine Stimme ja irgendwie rausgerechnet wird und dementsprechend weniger Prozente bei denen reichen für eine Mehrheit.
Also sprich wenn ganz viele Leute kleine Parteien wählen oder nicht wählen dann wird das dann am Ende rausgerechnet so dass du beispielsweise dann auch mit 45% eine Mehrheit hast und sowas.
Das ist ein bisschen trickreich ja.
Also im Prinzip ich tendiere ja persönlich ein bisschen mit der Stimme aus.
Also im Prinzip ich tendiere ja persönlich aktuell zur FDP und das würde auch insofern passen weil die kommen auf jeden Fall über 5%.
Die FDP sind halt auch Schwätzer Steuersenkungen erzählen die immer die haben auch das letzte Mal wo die mit in die Regierung gekommen sind was von Steuersenkungen erzählen und gemacht haben sie es nicht.
Das Problem ist immer das Geschwätze davor und zu dem was gemacht wird und dass die Leute keinerlei Bezug mehr zu dem haben was gesagt wurde und was davon gemacht wurde bis zur nächsten Wahl.
Das hieß ja auch bei uns mit den Grünen in Hessen ganz viel versprochen nichts davon gemacht und Ausrede ist ja wir hätten mehr bestimmen bekommen müssen.
Fall bescheuert.
Gut ne also wie gesagt der zweite Punkt finde ich ja vollkommen in Ordnung.
Es darf keine anonymen Briefkastenfirmen mehr geben.
Gehören auf die schwarze Liste für Steuern was soll uns das was soll uns das jetzt sagen.
Also generell wenn Amazon keine Steuern bezahlt und man will was dagegen machen habe ich da keine Schmerzen mit.
Das finde ich beispielsweise auch bescheuert wenn das das so ist wie ich das interpretiere aktuell bezahlst du doch 25% oder aktuell bezahlst du 25% für wenn du wenn du Gewinn mit Aktien und sowas machst.
So warum sollte ich da drauf oder ich sag jetzt ich stellvertretend für diejenigen der es betrifft.
Warum sollte man dann keine Ahnung wenn die das anheben auf was weiß ich wenn sie das hier anheben frag mich nicht 50% oder so ich weiß es ja nicht was sie vor haben.
Warum sollte ich statt 25% das doppelte bezahlen obwohl ich das komplette Risiko habe.
Also entweder verstehe ich das falsch oder es ist einfach fail und was was ich nicht haben will.
Man darf nicht vergessen wenn ich irgendwelche Aktien kaufe oder Kryptowährung oder irgendwelche ETF Geschichten was weiß ich wie ihr wisst ich bin nicht der große Finanzguru.
Dann habe ich das komplette Risiko wie welches Risiko ich habe wenn ich was kaufe und das ist nach einem Jahr nichts mehr wert dann habe ich das komplette Risiko.
Ja wie welches Risiko ich kaufe Bitcoin und Bitcoin fällt.
Also wenn ich jetzt Bitcoin gekauft hätte bevor Elon Musk der Meinung war zu sagen Tesla nimmt keine Bitcoins mehr da hätte ich ziemlich gelitten.
So dementsprechend finde ich es auch vollkommen gerechtfertigt dass ich den Großteil dessen davon bekomme wenn ich eben richtig liege.
Also wenn ich Bankrott gehe bekomme ich Unterstützung von Steuern Geldern ich hoffe ja nicht dass ich Bankrott gehe.
Was wie no way.
Ja ist das also was was sehe ich denn jetzt da falsch dran.
Mal angenommen mal angenommen ich hätte mir vor zwei Wochen Bitcoin gekauft.
So und Bitcoin ist jetzt um 30% gefallen.
Dann habe ich im Endeffekt 30% weniger Geld.
Oder nicht.
Oder 50%.
Oder 50% dann habe ich 50% weniger Geld.
So mal angenommen ich hätte mir das jetzt gekauft.
Und es wäre 50% gestiegen dann hätte ich 50% mehr Geld wenn ich dann wieder verkauft hätte.
So also ich meine im Endeffekt also wir gehen natürlich davon aus ich behalte es dann nicht sonst wie ich sage ich mache mich vom Acker sondern habe ich 30% weniger Geld.
Es ist ja vollkommen egal hätte wenn und wie mal angenommen ich hätte das jetzt gemacht.
Warum soll ich komplett das Minus quasi selbst tragen aber fast die Hälfte dann davon abgeben wenn ich Gewinn mache das verstehe ich nicht oder ich verstehe es falsch.
Ach das gibt es nur das gibt es nur für Aktien und Zinsen.
Guck mal hier der Chat ist wieder Massive Brained.
Das heißt wenn ich jetzt Geld verdiene mit Krypto Stellz dann wie muss ich das dann versteuern?
Ganz ganz normal wie wenn ich keine Ahnung irgendjemand mein Auto verkaufe.
Wobei nehmen wir doch ja gut aber ich halte doch Bitcoin ich halte doch aktuell so wie das hin und her eine Bitcoin noch nicht ein Jahr.
Ich behalte doch kein Jahr eine Bitcoin.
Doch mach ich das? Weiß ich nicht ob ich das mache.
Ich also ich mache das ja eh nicht.
Hodl ja Hodl ja gut dann gehen wir mal von was an.
Dann nehmen wir jetzt nicht Bitcoin dann gehen wir mal davon aus ich hätte irgendwelche Aktien gekauft.
Ich will nur wissen ob ich das jetzt grundsätzlich verkehrt verstehe.
Weil angenommen ich hätte Aktien gekauft und die wären gefallen und dann hätte ich gesagt Scheiße ich verkaufe wieder alles dann hätte ich weniger Geld.
So ich kaufe mehr Aktien und das geht voll ab und ich verkaufe es wieder und habe dann mehr Geld.
Ich bin doch der einzige der das Risiko hat bei der ganzen Geschichte weil ich mich verspekuliert habe also ich habe es verkackt.
So also ich habe es verkackt okay aber wenn ich es verkackt habe dann muss ich das komplett.
Ja genau ich habe spekuliert aber ich habe spekuliert und habe verloren okay.
Dann habe ich ja auch keine Probleme zu sagen gut ich habe es verkackt ich habe es nicht besser ich habe es nicht besser verdient.
So und wenn ich jetzt aber Gewinn mache warum soll ich dann 50% darauf bezahlen.
Also sprich ich bezahle ja jetzt schon quasi von dem wenn ich richtig gelegen habe in ordentlichen Batzen.
So und warum soll ich dann nochmal mehr bezahlen obwohl derjenige das bekommt absolut kein Risiko daran hatte.
Ja weil der Staat mit verdienen will das ist mir klar aber warum muss es noch mehr sein.
Also ich glaube schon dass ich das im Prinzip richtig verstanden habe was uns das sagen soll.
Ich soll anstatt 25% darauf dann demnächst wahrscheinlich irgendwie keine 48-50% Steuern bezahlen.
Und wenn ich Minus mache habe ich halt gelitten war ja jetzt auch schon so.
Damit der Staat die ganzen Sozialprogramme finanzieren kann naja also ich verstehe es halt nicht wo das ganze Geld hingeht.
Wie gesagt wir sind die viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt.
Also ich meine wenn wir das Geld nicht haben dann machen wir da grundsätzlich was falsch oder aber was auch eine andere Möglichkeit ist.
Wir machen einfach viel viel viel zu viel mehr als das wofür wir Geld haben.
Wo ich mich dann frage wie kann das sein dass es beispielsweise im Gesundheitssystem noch vor nicht all zu langer Zeit besser gelaufen ist.
Was natürlich auch passieren kann ist was doch auch sein könnte ist dass die Leute jetzt alle sagen habe ich keinen Bock mehr ich gehe nach Dubai oder.
Also aber angenommen es gibt ganz viele Leute die sagen ich habe keinen Bock da gehen die zu Simon Desue nach Dubai.
Aber machen sie schon. Ja das ist ja alles in Ordnung.
Aber ganz im Ernst ich habe keinen Bock mehr Steuern zu bezahlen.
Und ich bin der Meinung wir haben sicher also wir müssen genug Geld haben wenn wir nicht genug Geld haben hat keiner genug Geld.
Man muss sich halt nur mal gucken wo das hin fließt aber da bin ich zu wenig informt das im Detail zu wissen.
Aber wenn wir nicht genug Geld haben hat keiner genug Geld.
Und außerdem bezahlen wir anteilmäßig kommt ja auch noch dabei wir bezahlen ja anteilmäßig auch schon saumäßig viel Steuern.
Na gut wir gucken jetzt ein paar Videos zumindest als ich das gesehen habe mit ich soll wahrscheinlich mehr Steuern bezahlen hatte ich keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Ja das stimmt.
Oh jetzt gibt es hier die Diskussions im Chat.
So gut Sendflats zu abgelassen gucken wir mal was können wir uns dann angucken.
Zeigt mir was haben wir denn für Youtube Witz was kriegen wir denn empfohlen.
Oh nee habt ihr das auch gerade gesehen.
Habt ihr das auch gerade gesehen.
Da war der Typ der mich von Kabel 1 letztes mal so getriggert hat hier unten irgendwo gerade.
Oh nee Leute wir haben zu viel von dieser komischen Sendung geguckt.
Jetzt kriegen wir den best empfohlen.
Ich muss kann ich konnte man nicht irgendwie sagen interessiert mich nicht das geht glaube nur wenn man eingeloggt ist.
Ich bin hier nicht eingeloggt.
Nutze einen Adder namens BlockTube du kannst nur Youtube Empfehlung blocken.
Ja ich will ich will nicht den Kram da das Sat1 Zeug triggert mich.
Physix Dankeschön für den Prime Sub.
Muss mal kurz gucken ich habe bestimmt 40 Subs übersehen.
Nee habe ich nicht gut sonst hätte ich es wieder verkackt.
Das muss er auch erst mal schaffen 19.000 Euro Nachzahlung was hat er denn getrieben dafür.
So also was gucken wir uns jetzt mal an hier.
Windows Major Update ok Leute das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken die nächste Windows Version was da huge Sachen reinkommt.
Spoiler ich kenne das Video nicht aber ab wo geht es denn los.
Wir haben uns das Change Log angeguckt von Microsoft und es ist absolut lächerlich was es neue Features gibt im aktuellen Windows Update.
New Features und Changes ich frage mich wie es der Typ schafft na gut 4 Minuten Video das ist ja nicht lang.
Genau das haben wir uns angeguckt und haben uns gedacht wollt ihr uns verarschen dafür macht ihr ein Windows Update.
Blablabla
Ok
Der weiß auch nicht mehr.
Jetzt ernsthaft es ist wirklich nur das.
Es ist wirklich nur das.
Ey das ist ernsthaft das ist eines der unsinnigsten Sachen überhaupt.
Ich meine überlegt euch mal überlegt euch mal die Leute sagen seit Jahrzehnten kann man ja wann kam Windows 10 raus.
Windows 10 Release Date
Ok na Jahrzehnten ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Die Leute sagen seit Jahren schon was weiß ich die zwei verschiedene Settings Menüs sind bescheuert.
Die Windows Standard Programme sind kacke.
Voreinstellter Gramm ist blöd irgendwelche Privacy Sachen sind blöd was auch immer ja.
Also es gibt viele valid Kritikpunkte an Windows.
Aber was glaube ich keiner bisher jemals gesagt hat ist ich brauche hier unten ein neues Widget wo ich drauf klicke wo ich da News und Wetter angezeigt bekomme.
Aber da hat sich Microsoft einfach gedacht das ist das was die Leute brauchen.
So ein unsinniger Schwachsinn wahrscheinlich kommen auch noch die ganzen Sachen über Bing.
Was für ein Scheiß.
Oh Gott Microsoft ist.
Braucht doch echt kein Mensch.
Das braucht doch wirklich absolut kein Mensch.
Chat mal ne Frage an euch jetzt wo ihr das gesehen habt sagt irgendetwas.
Jawoll das werde ich verwenden.
Ok ich kenne den Chat der jebaitet mich jetzt und sagt ja.
Ich kenne den Chat immer wenn ich sowas frage sagen die Leute ja klar natürlich verwende ich das.
Stimmt es gibt ja die Windows VR App die habe ich noch nie geöffnet aber ich habe noch kein VR Headset.
Oh Microsoft macht Windows ganz.
Das Problem haben wir auf der Arbeit.
Ich weiß nicht ob ich euch das schon erzählt habe aber ich glaube schon wir haben jetzt ja die große Ehre dass wir Windows Defender auch auf allen Linux Systemen installiert haben.
Das ist kein Scherz ist wirklich so wir haben Windows Defender auf allen Linux Systemen also es heißt ja nicht Windows Defender es heißt ja Microsoft Advanced Threat Protection heißt das ja.
Es heißt ja nicht mal Windows Defender das heißt Microsoft Advanced Threat Protection das ist aber eine Windows Defender.
Wir haben Windows Defender auf allen unsere Linux Kisten drauf mittlerweile und das Schlimme ist ihr jetzt auch es ist gerade angesagt im Business Management Umfeld.
So und wisst ihr was witzig ist das Ding sendet zig tausend Logs und Reports zu Microsoft es gibt da so ein eigenes Frontend bei Microsoft wo man sich die ganzen Reports und Logs angucken kann von allen Systemen.
Wo der Windows Defender das reported hat und das geile ist das Ding lockt manchmal Passwörter mit.
Ein Kollege von mir hat diese Log Auswertung aufgemacht hat reingeguckt und hat gesagt da steht doch mein Passwort im Klartext drin.
Wahrscheinlich weil es halt der hat ein Befehl eingegeben aus Versehen war sein Passwort drin und easy mit gelockt nach Azure beste.
So und dann kam noch der Hit Windows Defender hat reported unser File Server ist Security ich weiß gar nicht mehr was das geschrieben hat.
Also Windows Defender hat auf unserem File Server irgendwie keine Ahnung 78 Sicherheitsangriffe oder irgendwas in der Richtung erkannt hat es reported.
Und dann haben wir gedacht hö wie jetzt warum ist auf unserem File Server denn so viel Security.
Und dann haben wir nachgeguckt und dann haben wir festgestellt Windows Defender hat reported das offene File Handles lange offene File Handles existieren.
Da habe ich mir gedacht was auf einem File Server offene File Handles das kann ja nicht sein das muss eindeutig Hacker Angriff sein.
Also wenn das kein Hacker Angriff ist dann weiß ich auch nicht. Und so ein Schwachsinn müssen wir uns da mittlerweile angucken.
Ich meine das auf dem File Server File Handles offensin das kann also da kann man ja das kann ja eigentlich nicht sein.
Was ist ein offener File Handle für Noobs? Ein File Handle ist oh fuck wie erkläre ich das jetzt.
Oh fuck wie erkläre ich das jetzt. Also wenn du eine Datei öffnen willst dann darfst du ja nicht direkt auf die Festplatte zugreifen.
Ich versuche es mal ich versuche es mal so zu erklären.
Also das weiß ich du darfst schon aber du hast ja also wenn du jetzt eine Datei öffnen willst dann hast du ja keine Ahnung von den Bites auf der Festplatte.
Das heißt du gehst zu deinem Betriebssystem.
Das heißt du gehst zu deinem Betriebssystem und sagst Betriebssystem ich würde gerne diese Datei öffnen.
Und dann gibt dir dein Betriebssystem ein File Handle und dieses File Handle kannst du dann verwenden um die Datei zu lesen und zu schreiben.
Du musst dem Betriebssystem auch sagen ob du die Datei öffnen willst lesen schreibend oder was auch immer.
Du sagst dann zum Beispiel hey Linux oder hey Windows ich möchte gerne die Datei clap.gif öffnen.
Und dann gibt dir Windows ein File Handle und dieses File Handle kannst du dann verwenden um zu sagen ich möchte jetzt lesen.
Und dann nimmst du das File Handle sagst du ich möchte daraus lesen und gut ist.
Ich mein du brauchst das theoretisch nicht du könntest wahrscheinlich auch wenn du die Rechte dazu hast nen User Sighting NTFS File System Treiber nehmen und Bites einlesen und dann interpretieren und wie auch immer.
Das wird wahrscheinlich auch funktionieren aber die einfachere Variante ist auf jeden Fall das über das Betriebssystem zu machen.
Der Desktop ist Poggers. Ich weiß gar nicht was der Chat immer gegen meinen Desktop hat.
Der Desktop ist Massive. Und außerdem sieht er ja nur wegen dem Chat so aus.
Weil guck mal hier alles E-Modes.
Was hältst du von Linux umstellen und fürs zocken dann vms nix?
Gar nix.
Damit machst du dir mehr Probleme als umgedreht. Ich kann dir eher empfehlen wenn du Linux verwenden willst und wenn du unter Linux nix wirklich wenn du kein Blender verwenden willst unter Linux oder sowas.
Dann mach Windows drauf und mach deine VM unter Windows dann sieht das bei dir so aus.
Kannste beispielsweise machen wie ich das hier auch immer hab.
Mach mal kurz die VM an.
Machst du die VM ins Fullscreen. Dann hast du hier dein Zeug drauf und wenn du Linux verwenden willst switchst du einfach den Desktop und hast hier dein Linux.
Das ist viel angenehmer als umgedreht. Linux läuft in der VM super.
Windows schwieriger.
Also ich halte davon nix. Es sei denn man möchte mal was technisch herausforderndes machen und möchte auf gar keinen Fall Windows auf seinem Rechner installieren.
Dann ist das die einzige Variante die man machen kann. Aber ich würde Usability technisch nicht empfehlen.
So und jetzt switchst du rüber, hast dein Linux, switchst du zurück, hast dein Windows. Switchen ist by the way Control-Windows-File-Taste.
Welche Distro ist für eine VM gut geeignet? Eigentlich alles was keine 2D, 3D Beschleunigung großartig benutzt. Also das ist eher eine Frage wie du es eingerichtet hast.
Ich habe hier Manjaro mit i3. Das ist aber gewöhnungsbedürftig, dass da alles im Fullscreen ist. Was du auch verwenden kannst ist sowas wie Ubuntu XFCE oder sowas. Auch wenn ich XFCE jetzt nicht so toll finde, aber es ist auf jeden Fall besser als ein aktuelles Gnome oder ein aktuelles KDE in der VM.
Wobei das auch geht, aber ich finde das schöner in der VM zu benutzen als ein Gnome. Ihr verwendet auch Arch habe ich gehört. Chat by the way.
Screen? Nee wie hieß das? Ach wie hieß dieses Ding was nochmal Logos anzeigt wenn man das eintippt. Das was ich nie verwende, was aber immer cool aussieht, was jeder auf sein... Screenfetch, genau.
Das hat jeder immer auf Reddit installiert wenn dann ein Screenshot von seinem... Das meine ich. Was gibt es noch? Warum ist NeoFetch besser?
NeoFetch. Oh ja NeoFetch sieht fancierer aus. Für was sind denn da unten die komischen Dinger? Ja also das Ding das verwenden die Leute auf Reddit immer gerne um zu posen was sie für Dinger haben.
Aber warum zeigt es die Color Palette von meiner Konsole? Was interessiert mich das? Also doch wenn ich auf Reddit poste. Ok dann ist das wirklich einzig und allein dafür erstellt worden um auf Reddit zu posten was man hat. Verstehe.
So wir machen das erstmal fertig hier. Das Wit. So also im Prinzip ist in den Winners Update nichts drinne.
Ok. Ah ok. Also das wars mit neuen Features. Geiles Update oder? Bestes Winners Update aller Zeiten. Also ich glaube ohne das hätten wir es nicht überlebt.
Genau machen wir mal ein bisschen bundig das ganze. So. Das ist doch viel besser.
Äh Moment wie ging das? Konnte man da nicht irgendwas ausführen lassen? Scheint ging das doch nicht. Watch aber das funktioniert da nicht mit. Äh das stimmt das Escape nicht. Weil man könne. Ah yes. Jetzt hier. Hackerman Modus aktiviert.
Jetzt können wir uns angucken was in meinem Rechner drinne ist. In High Speed 60 FPS. Moment sind das überhaupt 60 FPS? Sack. Warum geht mein Nvidia Zeug nicht?
Geforce Experience. Das hat sich wieder ausgeloggt. Warum brauche ich für meinen Grafikkarten Treiber überhaupt einen Login? Warum brauche ich einen Login dafür?
So. Jetzt haben wir den Hackerman Modus aktiviert. Das machen wir mal wieder aus.
Ok Chat. Was? Ja ich verstehe nicht. Ich verstehe nicht warum.
Ja ich glaube wir haben ganz gute Chancen mit dem aktuellen Winners Update das nichts kaputt geht.
Was? Frage beziehungsweise inwieweit hast du dich mit DMS OCR in deine Ablage befasst? Nein habe ich nichts im Einsatz. Nee.
Ja. Mach ich aber nie. Ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Es gibt das Experimental mäßig. Gibt es das schon? Haben wir sogar letztens in einem der Streams ausprobiert.
Das ist richtig. Ja zum Spielen ist das nichts in der VM. Aber Linux läuft in der VM deutlich besser als Winners finde ich. Also als Winners im umgekehrten Fall.
Kannst du Proxmox empfehlen? Ja wenn man GUI braucht ist das nicht verkehrt. Ich persönlich mag meinen Ubuntu Server mit Ubuntu und Ubuntu drauf am liebsten.
Ich würde es jetzt nicht verwenden aber wenn man einen GUI braucht und viele VMs laufen lassen will ist es sicherlich im privaten Bereich nicht verkehrt.
Ich glaube Business technisch gerade auf Support mäßig ist es jetzt nicht so verbreitet. Da ist VMW das Ding was vorne ist gefolgt von Citrix und Xen.
Also Citrix eher im virtuellen Desktop Bereich und VMW für den Rest.
Welche VM Umgebung empfiehlst du? Ja wie gesagt das VMW Workstation ist das beste.
Wie Chat? Chat? Es gibt Leute die reden normal miteinander im Chat. Was ist denn hier los?
Warum wird jetzt nicht die Mutter beleidigt oder sonst was? Warum wird normal gesprochen?
Ich glaube es ja nicht. Der Chat hier ist einfach zu schlau mittlerweile.
Der Chat ist einfach zu weit entwickelt mittlerweile. Das geht schon komplett an dem vorbei wo Twitch Chat für gedacht ist.
Was ist mit QEMO Wirkmanager kann man auch verwenden. Ist ja auch das einzige was du unter Linux sinnvoll verwenden kannst wenn du nicht VMW oder VirtualBox nehmen willst.
Wie kann ich VMW Fullscreen machen dann den Desktop switchen? Einfach VMW Fullscreen machen und den Desktop switchen.
Just Desktop switchen. VirtualBox mag ich nicht so. Die GUI und das Handling von VMW Workstation ist einfach viel besser.
Wird VirtualBox noch weiter entwickelt? Wahrscheinlich. Aber es ist halt Oracle. Da weißt du nie.
Workstation Pro. Vor allem Workstation Pro. Kauft ihr irgendwo einen Key? Oder wo auch immer du dir den Key hierher besorgst ist mir egal. Aber kauft ihr einen Key für 15 Euro bei irgendeinem Key Shop und gut ist.
Also gucken wir mal weiter. Wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Was habe ich denn hier auf Fachinformatik? Warum habe ich das offen? Ich habe sogar explizit danach gesucht.
Wahrscheinlich wollte ich gucken ob es irgendwelche Cringe Ausbildungsvideos gibt. Gibt es Cringe Ausbildungsvideos?
Wieso fehlt bei der Katze die halbe Nase? Weil der Chainlord das nicht richtig ausgeschnitten hat.
Sucht mal. Ausbildung Fachinformatik. Fachinformatik. Ausbildung in 360 Grad. Jetzt wird es aber advanced. Moment Moment.
Moment Moment. Physi-Ausbildung in 300 Grad. Eieiei VR. Jetzt wollen sie es aber echt wissen.
Hast du unsere zwei Azubis schon entdeckt? Hey, wir sind hier oben. Okay, das ist Cringe.
Hey, wir sind hier oben. Okay, das ist tatsächlich Physi-Cringe.
Ein bisschen leise, oder? Ein bisschen leise. Warte mal, ich muss kurz gucken, dass die laut stehen. Hallo Lukas.
Es sieht richtig nach 4K aus, findet ihr nicht auch? Also hat schon was von 4K. Aber guck mal, man kann hier sogar.
Schnell. Wow. Viel zu leise? Wirklich?
Guck mal, jetzt kann man denen zugucken. Guck mal, ein Druckeranschließer. Ein Druckeranschließer.
Die haben doch dieses Büro. Haben die doch explizit für das Video jetzt hier hingestellt, oder?
Und dann haben sie dann gesagt, setzen sie sich mal hier hin und tun so, als würden sie arbeiten. Und das andere Video haben wir schon geguckt, das war wirklich Cringe.
Leute, wir haben übrigens für die Katze noch ein zweites Bild zur Auswahl. Aber ich finde, die hätten wir noch. Was meint ihr ist besser? Die, die jetzt schon unten sitzt oder die hier auf dem Chat?
Aber die, die jetzt schon da sitzt, ist glaube ich irgendwie passender, oder? Beide?
Okay, okay. Chico 2. Wir probieren das jetzt mal aus. Ich muss mal kurz unterbrechen. Wir probieren das jetzt mal kurz aus. Chico 2. Pile. Chico 2. So.
Ist gar nicht schlecht. Ist gar nicht schlecht. Ich muss mir das gerade mal kurz in der Vorschau angucken. Moment, hier im zweiten Bildschirm in der Vorschau angucken.
Das, das finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Ich glaube, ich lasse die heute mal drinne, die neue.
Die neue. Umfrage ist am Start. Welches Bild? Ja, dann. Dann Polt mal.
50, 50, what the fuck? Okay, dann werde ich es einfach so, also wenn das weiter so ausgeht, werde ich einfach, ähm, ah, ah, alles holt auf, alles holt auf. Nein.
Wenn ich einfach immer mal das eine und mal das andere mache. Okay, es ist nicht genau 50, 50. Das ist Cringe? Okay, wahrscheinlich.
Tja, dann, dann lasse ich heute das neue Bild und das nächste Mal mache ich dann wieder das alte Bild und schalten wir ein bisschen hin und her und gut ist.
So, aber jetzt erstmal, jetzt muss ich mir erstmal hier, Zack, jetzt müssen wir uns erstmal die Sache mit, mit in 3D angucken.
Warum hatten die keine Tastatur?
Warum hat die keine Tastatur? Wait a minute. Was, was macht die denn überhaupt? Die, die macht, die benutzt nur sie.
Oder wir sehen die Tastatur nicht. Oder wir sehen, Moment, Freunde.
Kriegen wir irgendwie einen Winkel hin? Da ist doch im Leben keine Tastatur.
Aber da geht ein Kabel hin, was jetzt hier runter geht.
Wartet mal, wartet mal, wir müssen es jetzt genauer.
Hier, guck mal, guck mal da, das da. Könnte das die Tastatur sein?
Diese Ecke, die hier rausguckt. Es muss auf jeden Fall eine kleine Tastatur sein.
Beschaffung, Installation und Wartung von Hardware wie Laptops, Servern oder Druckern.
Da, da, da, Leute, ich sehs, da, guck mal. Hier, hier ist eine Tastatur.
Exposed, kein Fake, real.
Außerdem ist der Verarbeiten am Netzwerk und die Integration neuer Lösungen in die Systemlandschaft zuständig.
Ein wichtiger Teil seiner Aufgabe besteht darin, Kolleginnen und Kollegen in die Anwendung...
Mini DisplayPort, oder? Ganz ehrlich, exakt so würde ich das auch verkabeln.
Ich hab null Bock immer diesen Kram zu verkabeln. Bei mir sieht das auch immer wie Sau aus.
Fake, Fake, guck mal, die wollen es nicht ernsthaft erzählen, dass sie so viel Zeit haben.
Reizt auch in die ausländischen Niederlassungen bei Grenke und gab ihm die Chance, sein Fachenglisch zu verbessern.
Julian...
Hat er ihr gerade gezeigt, wie man den Monitor einschaltet?
Ja, da musst du draufdrücken zum Einschalten, guck da, ah, da geht der Monitor an.
Julian macht die Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker.
Wir gucken uns mal das an, ah, ich wollte gerade sagen, wir gucken uns mal das an, was man nicht sieht.
Mit dem Schwerpunkt Anwendungsentwicklung, wobei er alle relevanten Inhalte und Herangehensweisen für die Softwareentwicklung lernt.
Hey Julian, ich hab die Hardware aufgebaut, wie sieht's mit der Software aus?
Natürlich, Standardfrage, Standardfrage, so unterhält man sich immer im Gang.
Na klar, na klar.
Wir fahren nach Karlsruhe zu den Anwendungsentwicklern.
Was?
Wir fahren nach Karlsruhe zu den Anwendungsentwicklern für die Software für das neue Notebook, oder was?
Wir entwickeln die Software in kleinen Teams, damit jeder seine Ideen einbringen kann.
Was ist, was macht der eigentlich jetzt dabei, außer dabei zu sein?
In der Softwareentwicklung wird die Programmierung von verschiedenen Applikationen geklamt und durchgeführt.
Dafür muss man nicht nur...
Ich frag mich bei solchen Videos immer, also wir haben ja auch so einen bei mir in der Firma, also nicht bei meiner, also bei, wow, what the fuck.
Ähm, also da wo ich arbeite, wir haben ja auch so einen Werbefilm gedreht.
Und bei uns wurde halt auch extrem gefaked.
Also bei uns wurde ein Werbefilm gedreht und ich war ja an dem, ich hatte ja Glück, der der Sache beiwohnen zu dürfen, zumindest bei den Vorbereitungen.
Da wurde extrem gefaked und zwar hat man den, ähm, dort wurde 24-7, also wir haben quasi so ein Team, was 24-7 da ist und äh, Monitoring-Sachen sich anguckt und äh, Sachen eskaliert, wenn was kaputt geht und so.
Das ist quasi so ein, äh, wie nennt man das? Operation Center.
Und das haben die vorgestellt in dem Video.
Und das Problem war, das saßen halt nur, so wie das IT-technisch halt öfters, öfters mal so der Fall ist, das saßen bei uns halt nur junge bis ältere weiße Männer.
Das war aber für die heutige Zeit wohl nicht divers genug.
Deswegen hat man kurzerhand einfach mal geguckt, wie man so, wie man mal so ranbekommt.
Und am Ende saßen da glaub ich drei Mädels mit dabei, also man hat die Hälfte eh schon nicht gezeigt, ja.
Saßen drei Mädels mit dabei, nen Schwarzen hatten wir mit dabei und noch, also von den drei Mädels noch eine mit Kopftuch.
Also sprich, dieses Video wurde so krass auf diverse gemacht, dass es einfach besser wirkt in der heutigen Zeit.
Deswegen frage ich mich bei solchen Videos auch immer, weil ich es halt immer aus erster Hand kenne, Ken, was haben sie hier zurecht gefakt wieder?
Okay, also wie geht's denn weiter hier? Hackermans.
Hallo.
Aha.
Leute, ich hab's.
Er hat's, Leute, er hat's.
Und jetzt?
Und?
Das hatte ich, das hatte ich auch noch nie.
Das, das, das hab ich noch nie erlebt, dass ich gesagt hab, ich hab's und das ganze Büro ist zu mir an den Bildschirm gerannt.
War hier.
Übrigens, huge, huge, huge acting.
Leute, ich hab's.
Was soll uns das hier über, die rennen ja alle dahin.
Was soll uns überhaupt diese, diese ganzen Zahlen hier sagen?
What the fuck?
Was, was soll das überhaupt sein?
Ich mein, das sind doch nicht mal Bites, das sind, fragt mich nicht, sinnlose Floats.
Hackerman Matrix.
Er hat's.
Boah, wie sie angerannt kommen, habt ihr das gesehen?
Wie sie angerannt kommen alle, weil er gesagt, ich hab's.
Ja.
Komm her.
Guckt euch mal den an, wie der angeflitzt kommt.
Und zwar hier.
Der ist ja voll, der ist ja voll am Sprinten dafür.
Haben wir ne Variable, die ähnlich benannt ist wie im Backend.
Und deshalb hat das Backend das falsch gepasst.
Okay.
Falschen Wert und deshalb haben wir den Bug.
Und wenn wir jetzt einfach.
Ja gut, wenn man auch alles in XML macht, dann ist das ja keine Frage.
Die Variable wieder umbenennen.
Oder CSV.
Wie sie ursprünglich hieß, dann existiert der Bug nicht mehr.
Und es wird alles korrekt ans Backend weitergegeben.
Und wird dann auch in der Datenbank gespeichert.
Und die Business Logik funktioniert wieder.
Ich glaube, die haben sich einfach Random-Sätze ausgedacht dafür jetzt.
Hab ich den Fehler gefunden.
Oh, oh, huge, huge.
Julian und seine Gruppe präsentieren gerade ihre gemeinsame Arbeit.
Als Fachin...
Ich würd's ja gerne erkennen.
Okay, was steht da?
Web-App?
Erkennt das jemand?
Das?
Was heißt denn das?
Man kann leider, man kann leider nur so Fett...
Fett zoomen.
Web-App?
V?
Ich muss mal ein bisschen weg.
Versenken.
Versenken steht da, oder?
Versenken der...
Ah, Versenden der Requests.
Validierung der Eingaben.
Bam.
Chat.
Huge Schwarmintelligenz wieder, was es gelöst hat.
Versenden der Requests.
Also sie haben eine Web-App.
Das validiert die Eingaben und dann werden die Requests versendet.
Man soll's auf Server vielleicht...
Ah, egal, weiter.
Asif.
Umruggelt das eigentlich?
Es ist egal, ob es um Hard- oder Software geht.
Tja.
Und deswegen guckt man auch eigentlich am Backend, ob das sinnvoll ist, was da an Requests reinkommt.
Das sieht mir nach Huge-Security-Problem aus von ihrer App, Alter.
Wenn die Web-App kleinzeitig validiert und dann alles ins Backend kommt und dort direkt in die Datenbank, das erscheint mir ein wenig problematisch, um es mal so auszudrücken.
Dadurch ist unsere Businesslogik kaputtgegangen.
Während Julian und Lukas jetzt ihren wohlverdienten Feierabend genießen, verabschieden wir uns und hoffen, du hattest einen guten Einblick in die Ausbildung als Fachinformatikerin oder Fachinformatiker bei Grenke.
Tschüss und bis zum nächsten Mal.
CU.
Wie würdest du es machen?
Ich würde auf dem Kleinen nur das Nötigste validieren und alles nur das, also nur...
Ich würde auf dem Kleinen nur das validieren, was ich dort brauche zum Anzeigen.
Also wenn ich zum Beispiel ein Formular habe und will, das geheiligert wird, der User hat sich vertippt, weil er eine nicht gültige E-Mail-Adresse eingegeben hat.
Das würde ich validieren, indem ich halt gucke, ist eine Ad drinne oder sowas und wenn nicht, dann mache ich das Form rot.
Aber das wirkliche Validieren, so nach dem Motto, da sind irgendwelche Sonderzeichen drin, die ich nicht verarbeiten kann oder es sind Escape-Sequenzen drin, die ich nicht haben will oder sowas.
Also dieses wirkliche Validieren, auch ob, keine Ahnung, es sind nur positive Zahlen drin oder was auch immer.
Das machst du auf Backend, weil da kommt es ja drauf an, dass keine Scheiße verarbeitet wird.
Was da im Frontend passiert, ist vollkommen egal.
Im Frontend machst du nur das, was du machen musst, dass es schön aussieht.
Im Backend musst du gucken, dass da keine Scheiße reingeschrieben wird.
Das ist übrigens das, was auch alle so machen, die irgendwie keinen Bock haben, dass die Leute für minus 50 Euro bei ihnen was bestellen.
Ja, das war mir klar, dass der erste jetzt wieder ankommt und sagt, wir machen keinen Regex für Mail.
Ich weiß, man kann E-Mails, glaube ich, also es gibt, glaube ich, keinen Regex, der wirklich jede gültige E-Mail-Adresse erfasst.
Wieso ist vor allem, wenn ich im Dark Mode, weil ich es nicht eingestellt habe.
Gut, jetzt haben wir wieder was gelernt. Man muss aber eins ihnen mal zugute halten.
Das Video ist nicht schlecht. Ich habe jetzt zwar ein bisschen drüber abgelästert, aber alles in allem muss man echt mal sagen,
ich habe schon ein 3D-Stells-Video, das war bestimmt nicht einfach zu produzieren, das ist nicht schlecht gemacht.
Finde ich, finde ich, finde ich gut.
Ich kann nicht mehr zoomen, Leute.
Aber ich wollte gucken, ob man erkennen kann, was da dransteht, aber nein, gibt's nicht.
War nicht schlecht gemacht.
So, mehr, was, was sollten ich mir noch angucken?
Das ist bestimmt auch cringe.
Oh, Paints-Champ.
Das ist tatsächlich nicht schlecht gemacht.
So sieht die Realität halt aus.
Der muss sich übelst wegpissen, das sieht man ja. Guck mal, der ist übelst am grinsen.
Guck mal, der muss sich eigentlich übelst wegschmeißen gerade.
Ah, die guten lila Netzwerk-Kabel.
Mein Name ist Janek, ich bin 19 Jahre alt und ich mache eine Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration im ersten Lehrjahr bei der BTW.
Was ihr hier seht, ist mein Arbeitsalter.
Ich arbeite direkt vor Ort und auch im Hintergrund.
Meine Arbeit ist daher sehr vielseitig.
In einem Moment unterhalte ich mich mit Kunden, höre mir deren Probleme an.
Unterhalten mit Kunden? OneKS?
Im nächsten Moment arbeite ich an einem Server und sorge für das reibungslose Arbeiten aller Computer und allen Betriebssystemen.
Ich schaffe Netzwerkstrukturen wie kabelgebundene Netzwerke oder WLAN-Netzwerke.
Ich stange Festplatten aus, installiere Drucker.
Oh ja, Drucker installieren, beste.
Durch meinen Beruf können Mitarbeiter mit ihren Computern und mobilen Handgeräten heute und auch morgen noch vernetzt arbeiten.
Mein Arbeitsfeld ist riesig und nur wenige sehen es.
Das stimmt.
Was machst du gerade so?
Joa, das übliche.
Das ist doch eine gute Werbung für Azubi-Stalls.
Das finde ich nicht schlecht.
Das ist tatsächlich realistisch gemacht.
Also mit realistisch gemachtem Wasser am Ende erzählen, dass die Aufgaben viel größer sind, als sich das die meisten Leute vorstellen.
Ja, ist echt so.
Ich meine, jeder von euch kennt es doch wahrscheinlich, der in diesem Bereich arbeitet.
Dieses Standard-Sache mit, du machst doch was mit Computer.
Das ist doch so Paynes-Champ immer.
Ja, ja, ich mache was, was mit Computer.
Das ist richtig.
Computer-Fuzzi bei Roffel Fensterbau.
So, schauen wir uns jetzt als nächstes an.
Komm mal dicht hier.
Upload-Filter in 17 Tagen.
18 Minuten Video.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er das jetzt...
Lohnt sich?
Hat es jemand schon geguckt?
Lohnt sich das zu gucken?
Ich meine, ich weiß, dass sie das beschlossen haben jetzt und sich da übrigens auch wieder krass rausgehen.
So nach dem Motto, ja, wir setzen nur EU-Vorgaben um.
Und wenn man dann nachguckt und feststellt, ah ne, die waren selbst maßgeblich daran beteiligt, dass es eingeführt wird, ist halt auch wieder dummes Gelaber.
Also jetzt nicht von ihnen hier, sondern von denen, die das Gesetz gemacht haben.
Vintage Japanese Railroad Padlock.
Alles klar.
Der Weep-Picking-Lawyer.
Okay, da wackelt einmal dran und es ist auf.
Ein interessantes Side-Note hier ist, dass Lock-Picks in Japan illegal sind.
Das würde einen Kriminal nicht auspicken.
Aber ich denke, dass es die Öffentlichkeit der Pick-Tools beeinflusst.
Und bis jetzt die Verschleißung der Pick-Knowledge.
Also, wir werden das öffnen.
Ein Akt, das illegal in der Lock-Nation ist.
Auch wenn ich die Lock habe.
Okay, danach, da ich ein Lawyer bin, der von der Gesetzgebung respektvoll ist, werde ich euch zeigen, wie man es ohne Lock-Pick öffnen kann.
Also, fangen wir mit dem Picken an.
Ah, ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, der benutzt jetzt irgendwas von dem Süßgraben, um das Schloss aufzumachen.
Okay, die übliche Geschichte.
It's binding, binding, binding.
Wie?
Click?
Ohne Binding?
Binding?
Noch Easier.
Easy as a f**k.
Easy.
Einfach ein Stück Metall reingeschoben, easy.
Der Typ ist geil, den gucke ich gern.
Den gucke ich gern.
Die Videos sind ja immer schön kurz und knackig.
Gibt's, gibt's nix.
So, wir müssen jetzt mal irgendwas, irgendwas anders.
Der Auer, was, was hat der dann?
Neue Netzteile ab 2022, na gut.
Ich brauch kein neues Netzteil.
Ich brauch erst ein neues Netzteil, wenn ich neue CPU, neue Grafikkarte hab.
Und das wird ja wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen dauern.
Unsere erste gemeinsame OC-Session nach fast sieben Jahren.
I7 920 Overclocking.
I7 920, ist das was Neues?
Ich blicke bei, ich blicke bei den Intel Bezeichnungen nicht mehr durch.
Ist, ist, ist ein I7 920 was Neues?
Ich hab einen I7 8700K.
Heißt das jetzt meiner ist neuer oder älter?
Ach, das meint er nach sieben Jahren.
Ach, das meint er mit nach sieben Jahren.
Ach so.
Ich dachte, ich dachte hier mit, wer auch immer Stefan ist.
Ich dachte mit Stefan macht der was nach sieben Jahren wieder.
Das ist First Gen I7.
Älter als Max, genau.
Mit dieser CPU haben sich meine Eltern kennengelernt.
Älter als ich.
Dieses Video wird mir übrigens laufend empfohlen, ne?
Immer in Deutsch und in Englisch parallel.
Dieses Video war gut, aber YouTube übertreibt es da gerade ein bisschen.
So, was haben wir denn ansonsten noch?
Why is Half-Life a Masterpiece?
Weil, weil Half-Life beste.
Robot Vacuum, ah ja, ja, das muss ich mir angucken.
Da bin ich gespannt drauf, weil das ist der erste Roboter
von Show Me, Show Me, Xiaomi, wie auch immer.
Ich kann mir immer nicht merken, wie man die ausspricht.
Der eine Auto-Cleaning-Basestation bekommt.
Also quasi eine Basestation, die den Roboter aussaugt.
Dann, also, der fährt an seine Docking-Station
und die Docking-Station macht ihn sauber.
Das ist der erste Roboter von denen, der das kann.
Kommt irgendwann, glaub, irgendwann noch dieses Jahr,
soll das, glaub, rauskommen.
Und ich hab ja die Hoffnung, dass darauf auf Custom,
dass dann auch Custom-Firmware mal irgendwann darauf laufen wird.
Weil auf den Vorgängern von diesem Roboter lief Custom-Firmware.
Der hört sich ja wahnsinnig gespannt an.
Der Typ hat eh die geilsten Aufbauten zum Testen.
Ich weiß, gibt es schon.
Aber alle, die das haben, die haben keine Möglichkeit,
sie ohne Cloud zu betreiben.
Ich glaube, das ist der erste Roboter,
der das gemacht hat.
Dann muss man, jaja,
du musst die Station sauber machen.
Aber die Station musste halt einmal im Monat sauber machen.
Den Roboter musste nach jedem Mal Saugen sauber machen.
Oh, wie? Der sackt weniger.
Das ist aber nicht gut, wenn er nicht genug sackt.
Siehste, das ist doch mal was.
Er sackt weniger, aber er macht sauberer als die anderen.
Das ist doch mal was.
Sackt brauche auch weniger Batterie,
vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Ich erkenne da jetzt nicht so viel Unterschied, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Hier oben sind noch ein paar Krübel.
Und ansonsten ist es Beleuchtung.
Ja, hier oben ist ein bisschen sauberer, guckt.
Ah, hier guckt mal, dazwischen meint der.
Ja, hier dazwischen, guck mal.
Hier dazwischen geht das viel, viel besser.
Hier steckt noch der ganze Schmodder drin und hier ist fast alles weg.
Das ist der Test für die Rillen, ich habe da oben drauf geguckt.
Hier guckt mal, ja, das ist tatsächlich ein Riesenunterschied.
Ey, wenn ich meinen Schaubsauger-Roboter rumdrehe
und an der Bürste wackele, ich würde denken, da ist was kaputt,
da ist was abgebrochen, wird stecken.
Aber das gehört anscheinend so.
Alter, geh weg, Browser, geh da unten fort.
Chrome, komm an, so.
Also sprich, das sackt besser, weil es mehr Kontakt zum Boden hat.
Ah, yes.
Ich muss sagen, das macht meiner eigentlich auch ganz okay.
Ich habe hier den S5, das ist ja quasi Vorvorgänger-Generation.
Der S5 ist auch gut im Katzenstreu aufsaugen, also da gibt es eigentlich nix.
Ja, das ist auch gut so, Laser, ja.
Guckt, so sieht das bei mir aus.
Ich zeige es euch mal.
Das ist ein Roborock-S7.
Guckt, so sieht das bei mir aus, ich zeige es euch mal.
Das ist die Map vom Wohnzimmer.
Und das Web-Interface habe ich nur, weil ich Custom-Firmware drauf habe.
Wohnzimmer-Leak.
Ja, das braucht auch keiner.
Kameras braucht keiner.
Ganz ehrlich, ich mag auch keine Kameras an meinem Staubsauger-Roboter haben.
Ich hätte dann immer bedanken, dass das Ding Bilder von meiner Wohnung in die China-Cloud schickt.
Welche Custom-Firmware?
Den Falle-Tudo-Fork.
Oh, guck mal, es funktioniert ja richtig gut.
Haben wir jetzt ein CE-Zeichen?
Ja, bestimmt, das kann man sich ja selbst drauftrocknen.
Da haben die Chinesen kein Problem mit.
Verwende ich nicht.
Kann meiner auch?
Hab ich doch nie verwendet.
Okay, das ist gut.
Das ist gut.
Deswegen verwende ich das übrigens auch nicht.
Weil ich keinen Bock habe, ich muss den dann zwei Mal fahren lassen.
Ich muss den einmal fahren lassen für da, wo er wischen soll.
Und einmal da, wo er saugen soll.
Das ist der hauptsächliche Grund, warum ich es nicht verwende.
Und weil ich keinen Bock habe, das in den Wassertank reinzumachen.
Oh, ist ganz okay.
Ja, genau.
Da bin ich echt mal gespannt, ob das was taugt.
Na, wahrscheinlich haben die Chinesen einfach Mist erzählt.
Das funktioniert dann einfach nicht damit.
Das ist bestimmt Chebathe.
Das geht wahrscheinlich nicht.
Er mag das Wort Gamechanger.
Was kostet denn der denn?
Wahrscheinlich 600?
Ja, ja, Topics.
Würde ich jetzt auch vermieten, vermuten so 600.
Darum haben die immer gekostet, die Top-Modelle.
Wo ist er denn?
Der hat eine Website.
Amazon, bei Amazon, Alter, bei Amazon.
Roborock S7.
Zeig mal her, kostet.
Das ist ein anderer.
Das ist, das ist, das ist Chebathe.
Das ist ein, das ist ein anderer.
Da heißt einfach nur auch S7.
Alter, da blickt doch keiner mehr durch.
Chinesenbenahmung.
Ja, das sieht schon ein bisschen, ein bisschen besser danach aus.
Zeig mal her, bei Amazon.
550, ja, da war man doch mit 600 Euro ganz gut beim, ganz gut geschätzt.
Also ich muss sagen, wie gesagt, ich hab den S5 und ich find den wirklich gut.
Gerade halt in Kombination, dass man den S5 noch mit Custom-Firmware flashen konnte.
Aber es ist, es ist jetzt, also wenn man damit keine Probleme hat, dass das Ding die China Cloud braucht, um zu funktionieren, dann, dann kann man sich den auch kaufen.
Das Gerät wird ja dadurch an sich hardware-technisch nicht schlechter.
Ich hab da nur keinen Bock drauf, dass ich China Cloud, dass ich eine China Cloud brauche, um einen Staubsauger benutzen zu können.
So, next, next, next, next, next.
So, gucken wir uns, gucken wir uns jetzt an, warum Half-Life das beste Game war.
Ich sag's euch, Half-Life ist Massive.
Oh nee, das geht 40 Minuten, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
40 Minuten, kommt jetzt grad 40 Minuten Half-Life Game an.
Half-Life Review, ich hab Half-Life glaube ich 85 mal durchgespielt.
Kann man die China Cloud nicht mit Piehole unterbinden?
Selbst wenn du das könntest, dann würde einfach dein Staubsauger nicht mehr funktionieren.
Weil er keine Verbindung mehr darin hat.
Ähm, ging es dir eher um den Sicherheitsgedanken?
Beides, beides, beides.
Also ich will nicht, dass ich meinen Staubsauger nicht verwenden kann, wenn mein Internetzugang nicht funktioniert.
Und ich hab auch keinen Bock, dass ich China Cloud Funktionen dafür brauche und Sachen hochlade.
Und dazu kommt, dass die Features in der Custom-Firma besser waren, zumindest zum damaligen Zeitpunkt.
Du hast einen Webinterface, worüber du steuern kannst, hast du zum Beispiel in der fertigen, in der standardmäßigen Ausführung nicht.
So ein Webinterface ist schon nice.
Über den Desktop hier einfach mal auf den Staubsauger.
Ich mein, guck mal, man kann über einen Browser auf seinen Staubsauger und starten.
Das ist schon cool, da brauchst du keine Smartphone-Apps.
Ich kann mich per SSH einloggen auf meinem Staubsauger.
Nicht, dass man das bräuchte, aber es ist auf jeden Fall cool, sich per SSH auf seinem Staubsauger einzuloggen.
Das kann man den Home Assistant einbinden, ja.
Kann man, kann man.
So, YouTube.
So, das haben wir schon geguckt.
Leute, wir gucken jetzt keinen 40 Minuten Half-Life 1-Video.
Kack Wade, Alter.
Wie zu lang.
Neo-Fetch müsste man glaube ich erst mal drauf inszenieren.
Was ist ein Neo-Fetch? Was ist Neo-Fetch? Ist das Go?
Dann könnte man es drauf kopieren und ausführen.
Warte mal, das machen wir jetzt. Moment.
Ist Neo-Fetch in Go? Ich brauche irgendwas, was auf einem ollen Armgedöns läuft.
Ah, das ist ein Bash-Programm. Ja gut, das geht auch.
Ok, ok Leute. Also, Staubsauger-Hackermans.
So, SSH auf den Staubsauger verbinden.
Ist ein bisschen langsam. Ist ein bisschen langsam, aber es funktioniert nach einer Zeit.
SSH auf den Staubsauger verbinden. Das sind wir.
So, Zeug raus machen, weil sonst die Leute wieder schreiben, ich habe etwas geleakt.
Dabei ist es vollkommen egal.
So, hier ist es.
Kann ich das nicht einfach suchen?
Ach nee, ich habe hier keinen Internet-Zugang.
So, SCP, SCP, Neo-Fetch auf den Staubsauger kopieren.
Neo-Fetch zeigt dir an, möglichst Twitter-Poser-mäßig, was auf deinem System läuft.
Mal gucken, ob das was anzeigen kann auf dem Staubsauger.
Mal gucken, was es anzeigt auf dem Staubsauger.
Also, so sieht es bei mir lokal aus.
CH-Mod, plus X, Neo-Fetch, Neo, Neo-Fetch.
Das funktioniert. Das läuft ernsthaft auf einem Staubsauger.
Es ist ein Ubuntu, es ist ein Ubuntu 14.04.
Arm, V7, L, was auch immer.
3-4er Colonel, also ist schon ein bisschen älter.
Es ist seit 8 Stunden ab, was merkwürdig ist.
Komische CPU, was auch immer das sein soll.
So sieht es aus, Leute.
Was machst du mit Ansible auf dem Staubsauger?
Ach, tatsächlich.
Ach ja, ich weiß, was ich mit Ansible auf dem Staubsauger gemacht habe.
Ich habe ein Zertifikat hinkopiert für SSL.
Ich habe Ansible auf dem Staubsauger.
Aber das ist also als Target, als Target, nicht als, nicht als wird von da ausgeführt.
Das ist ein Busybox, ja.
Das ist eine richtig echte Bash.
Aber ich denke mal, so Zeug wie AWK und so, wie tatsächlich.
Was ist minus H?
Minus, minus Version.
Mann, was ist das bei AWK?
AWK, minus, minus Help, gibt es da sowas?
Okay, zu, zu advanced.
Aber das ist, das ist anscheinend kein Busybox.
Das ist wahrscheinlich ein richtig echtes Ubuntu.
Nee, Mann geht nicht, Mann-Page geht nicht. Ja, vielleicht geht Help.
Drei Help, Help.
Ja, da ist ein richtig echtes Ubuntu drauf.
Info.
Nice, oder?
Äh, nee, ich zeige gerade meinen geflechten Staubsauger.
Ich habe gerade meinen geflechten Staubsauger gezeigt, was da alles,
dass man sich per SSH auf den Staubsauger verbinden kann.
Man könnte, man könnte übrigens Sachen installieren, aber das mache ich nicht.
Da ist ein Ubuntu 14.04 drauf, also sprich, wenn ich Internetzugang da wieder einschalte,
man könnte da was drauf installieren.
Und ich mache auch kein Dist-Upgrade, nee.
Wir hatten da doch sogar mal meinen Paket-Tracker drauf laufen, aus Spaß an der Freude.
AWK minus W version, was, ernsthaft?
Wirklich, minus W?
Nee, stimmt doch gar nicht.
Oder muss man wirklich so machen?
Fuck, was zum, warum, warum ist das AWK minus W Version?
Da, da, oh, da kommt doch kein Mensch drauf.
Meine Güte, für jeden Scheiß, irgendein anderer Befehl, äh, bei jedem, oh meine Güte.
Also ihr seht, es ist auch nicht unter, es ist auch nicht unter Linux alles, ähm, so toll, ne?
Alles seine Probleme.
Mein Copyright 1989, ja, aber AWK, die Version, die ich hier habe, die ist ja nicht von 1989.
Guck mal, die ist Copyright 1989 und dann bis 2020, bam.
Was auch immer, so, was gucken wir denn jetzt?
Können, wir können, wir, wir können uns den neuen, den neuen, äh, Raspberry Pi Arduino angucken,
der jetzt auch W-Lan hat, aber den würde ich nicht kaufen.
Zumindest für die meisten Projekte nicht, weil er viel zu teuer ist.
Die wollen, guckt euch, passt mal auf, wisst ihr was das kostet?
Das kostet 20 Euro.
Die wollen allen Ernstes 20 Euro oder, wo ist es denn überhaupt?
20 Euro, warum sollte ich einen Arduino mit W-Lan für 20 Euro holen,
wenn ich doch auch einfach einen ESP32 holen kann für 3,50 Euro, der auch noch, äh, schneller ist?
Also was, was genau ist der Vorteil davon?
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich verstehe es, ich verstehe die, die Daseinsberechtigung nicht.
Wahrscheinlich liegt es daran, weil da Raspberry Pi drauf steht und die Leute dann einfach denken,
oh, geil, Raspberry Pi, bam, kauf ich.
Ja, man bezahlt, genau, Evoli denke ich auch, man bezahlt den Name, wahrscheinlich, ja.
Müssen wir uns jetzt nicht angucken, das ist relativ langweilig, denke ich.
Und er hat neue Dinge eingebaut in seinem Smart Home, aber lasst mich raten, Kokona-Switche.
Kokona-Switche, typische Kokona-Switche, das geht bei uns überhaupt nicht.
Na, die Amis sind auch geil, ah, ich brauche einen neuen Schalter an der Wand.
Erstmal Säge holen und ein Loch in die Wand sägen und Schalter reinpacken.
Das kannst du bei uns halt so nicht machen, je nach Haus, es gibt bei uns bestimmt auch Holzer,
wo du das machen kannst, aber, also hier im Haus kann ich das garantiert nicht machen.
Ich hab halt Steine in der Wand und kein Holz.
So, wir können uns bei Level 4 angucken.
Leute, was ist denn mit YouTube los? YouTube zeigt heute, schlägt heute nichts Gescheites vor.
Was ist denn in einem Bauervideo?
Aber neue Netzteile interessieren mich eigentlich überhaupt nicht.
Einfach eine neue Wand über die alte Wand machen, ah, exellent.
Big Brain Idee und das dann immer weiter, bis der Raum irgendwann nicht mehr da ist,
weil alles Wand auf Wand ist.
Der Typ macht immer gute Videos, aber das ist mir zu Sixthead jetzt.
Der Algorithmus ist in Ordnung, kennst du das hier eigentlich?
Okay, YouTube, empfehle uns mal irgendwas Gescheites.
Oh, nicht den Typ, nicht diesen Typ, nicht diesen Typ, da kriege ich Anfälle, wenn ich das sehe.
Da bin ich schon direkt gereizt, nur wenn ich das Thumbnail sehe.
Ich kann auch nicht mehr anzeigen klicken, weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin.
Das ist ja heute wirklich ganz mau auf YouTube, ist ja wirklich ganz mau.
Why does rebooting fix everything?
Tja, das ist aber nicht nur bei Linux, mein Kühlschrank muss ich auch manchmal rebooten,
dann hört er auf zu brummen.
Stell euch mal vor.
Battlefield 6 Reveal Soundtrack.
Was gibt es eigentlich, Zack?
Reddit, gibt es neue Battlefield, krasse Battlefield Leaks?
Wir haben uns gar nicht von LevelCapture baiten lassen, dieses Woche, Moment.
Wo ist denn?
Der hat kein Chebat Video hochgeladen die Woche.
Ist der im Urlaub?
Das Layout der Mainboards ändert sich, okay.
Venice unleashed Zombies.
Ja, leider spielt Venice keiner mehr, das ist ja das Dumme.
Venice war eigentlich eine richtig geile Sache.
Mal gucken, Leute, lasst mal schätzen, wie viele Spieler online sind in Venice.
Also ich tippe auf insgesamt, also ich tippe auf, der vollste Server hat 5 Spieler.
5 Spieler, 5 Spieler, der vollste Server hat 5 Spieler.
Oh, 7, 7 sogar.
Ganze 7.
7 Spieler, Conquest Large.
Ja, war es, aber das hatte nicht nur Plaufilter weg, das hatte vieles.
Wieso ist das so gefloppt?
Ich glaube, also wie gesagt wissen tun wir es natürlich nicht so wirklich, aber
ich glaube, das liegt daran, weil die keine offiziellen Server hatten.
An sich finde ich, spielt sich das viel besser als Vanilla Battlefield 3.
Dazu kommt, dass Battlefield 3 eh schon keine großartige Playerbase mehr hat.
Die hätten zwei, drei offizielle Server machen müssen, wo du weißt, was dich erwartet,
die gut moderiert sind und wo man die Vorteile des Mods, also der Modding-Möglichkeiten sieht.
Aber halt jetzt nicht so übertrieben.
Was, Respirator, Satas, Stars und PC at the same time?
Okay.
War es doch.
War es doch, ich meine, das zu installieren war easy.
Und spielen tut sich auch besser als Vanilla.
Wenn du da nicht, das stimmt nicht, das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe auch gespielt, ich habe keine Ahnung, 5 Jahre kein Battlefield mehr gespielt.
Und ich habe da wieder angefangen zu spielen, habe richtig gute Runden gehabt.
Das ging, das ging.
Ich meine, Vanilla Battlefield ist jetzt auch nicht viel loupfreundlicher.
So, wir gucken uns das mal an, also.
Ja, aber warum?
Okay, warum ist nicht die Frage, weil es geht, ist wahrscheinlich die passende Antwort.
Was ist eigentlich mit dem Game, was Battlefield killen sollte?
Ja, das war Battlefield 5, meinst du?
Nee, ach du meinst World War 3 oder wie das hieß, stimmt.
Was ist eigentlich aus dem geworden, World War 3 Steam, gibt es das noch?
Nie wieder was vor, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das heißt.
Was ist eigentlich aus dem geworden, World War 3 Steam, gibt es das noch?
Ich habe das am Anfang mal ganz kurz reingeguckt, da war es komplett broken noch.
Oh, läuft ja gut.
Läuft ja richtig gut.
So sollte das mal aussehen.
Die Surfer sind aus, wirklich?
Haben die abgeschaltet?
Community is dead, naja gut. Na gut, das Spiel, mal gucken, ob das jemals rauskommt.
Was sagt es denn der Community Hub?
Die haben die Server abgeschaltet und wollen nochmal richtig umkrempeln.
Die müssten das Game mal, die müssten halt mal was.
Haben die das gesp...ach hier, ich wollte gerade sagen.
Ah Moment, wo waren wir?
So what happened to this game?
Das lese ich jetzt nicht durch.
Okay, es ist noch nicht raus, mal gucken, vielleicht erscheint es irgendwann.
Aber das wird dem Leben nichts.
Das wird genauso nichts wie...
Hat jemand gebacked von euch?
Any backers?
Die haben es voll verschissen, Alter.
Ich habe glaube 200 Euro gebacked.
Das kommt nie raus.
Das wird nie erscheinen.
Der traurige Stand des MMOs, ja.
Can't wait, Alter.
Ja, die sind sieben Jahre, oder davor auch schon.
Sieben Jahre und es ist nichts in dem Game zu sehen, was nach Game richtig aussieht.
Richtiger Fail, Alter.
Ja, das sollte mal ein Dark Nachfolger werden, aber die haben es so verkackt, Alter.
Noch nicht mal wie Star Citizen.
Star Citizen ist wenigstens in irgendeiner Art und Weise spielbar und man erkennt, dass sie viel gemacht haben.
Aber bei Camelot Unchained erkennst du gar nichts.
Ich müsste mal wieder auf den Testserver drauf.
Ich habe ja Early Access Backer Zugang.
Weil ich damals 200 oder vielleicht sogar noch mehr, ich weiß gar nicht, was es damals gekostet hat, gebacked habe.
Wahrscheinlich wird das das zweite Mal, wo ich richtig gescampt werde auf Kickstarter.
Das erste Mal gescampt auf Kickstarter wurde ich mit einer selbst reinigenden Hose.
Das habe ich ja schon mal erzählt.
Und jetzt wahrscheinlich Camelot Unchained.
Es gibt total viele Kickstarter Projekte.
Hier, warte mal.
Kickstarter Silver Jeans.
Hier, da haben sie mich gescampt hier.
Da haben sie mich gescampt mit der Hose.
Selbst reinigende Hose, ja.
Guck dir, selbst reinigende Hose.
By the way, 310.000 Euro von 10.000 finanziert und dann abgehauen.
Was soll eine selbst reinigende Hose machen?
Na ja, es soll sauber bleiben.
Guck hier.
Oh.
Haha, Kaffee ist weg.
Also ich mache das jetzt nicht laut, weil nicht, dass es noch jemand holen will und Scam ist.
An was es ist gescheitert, das weiß man nicht.
Ich meine, die Idee fand ich eigentlich echt cool.
Woran es gescheitert ist, weiß ich nicht.
Die sind einfach, die sind einfach verschwunden.
Ich habe, ich habe die auch, glaube ich, mit 150 Euro gebackt.
Da gab es irgendwie zwei Hosen und ein T-Shirt oder eine Hose und zwei T-Shirts oder irgendwie sowas.
Das hier.
Nee.
Shirt.
Also ich habe gebackt, dass ich mindestens eine Hose und ein Jeans kriege.
So, Update.
Wann gab es das letzte Update?
2018.
Kommentare.
Die wollen Refunds haben.
Scammed.
Nein, nein, ich habe nichts bekommen.
Die haben mich gefragt, wo sie es hinschicken sollen.
Das war das letzte, was ich jemals von ihnen gehört habe.
Scammed.
Richtig scammed.
Moment.
Oh, welcher Seite bin ich da jetzt rausgekommen?
Monkeys.
Das ist irgendeine chinesische Scam-Seite, wo ich jetzt rausgekommen bin.
Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass Adblock das meiste geblockt hat.
What the fuck.
AdSense.
Ach, das ist nur AdSense.
Okay.
Tja, guck mal, die haben 310.000 Dollar bekommen und haben wahrscheinlich einfach gesagt, okay,
wir hauen jetzt ab.
Ja, da haben sie mich richtig gescampt bei.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe seit dieser Geschichte und jetzt die Camelot
Unchained Geschichte, ich habe nur ganz wenig Kickstarter-Sachen noch gebacked.
Was habe ich denn noch?
Was habe ich denn noch Kickstarter gebacked?
Es ist nicht viel, nicht viel, seitdem die mich so gescampt haben.
Mir fällt jetzt gar nichts ein.
Ah, doch, ich weiß, was ich noch gebacked habe.
Das habe ich noch gebacked.
Full Stack.NET Standard IoT Plattform.
Das habe ich gebacked.
Die haben auch geliefert und habe ich bekommen.
Ein Testkit.
Das ist ein Microcontroller, auf dem quasi.NET läuft.
Allerdings, das liegt hier noch frisch eingepackt rum.
Ich habe es noch nie ausprobiert.
Tja.
Okay, was sollte ich jetzt noch gucken?
Moment, irgendjemand hat noch was verlinkt.
Das da, wollen wir gucken.
Genau.
Easy.
Was, was für ein Ding?
SFF TA 1.0, alles klar.
Das ist bestimmt irgendeine, irgendeine, äh, äh, SAS, SAS Geschichte.
SFF.
Die Sache ist die, es macht relativ wenig Sinn, das mit Raspberry Pi zu machen, aber es
ist da auch gar nicht der Grund des Videos, gehe ich mal von aus.
Es geht ja einfach darum, um zu zeigen, es geht.
Why?
Kioxia's latest drives, which I was trying to borrow from my own testing.
Ja gut, dann ist kein Wunder, dass ich mich damit nicht auskenne.
Aha, okay, siehste, der Chat weiß Bescheid. Excellent.
Ja, das ergibt keinen Sinn, aber es geht darum, zu zeigen, dass es geht.
Was ist denn das hier eigentlich? Einfach, ach nee, Moment, das ist das Kabel hier rüber.
Aber warum?
Nix, deswegen sackt der Raspberry Pi auch als nass. Also spätestens, wenn man die Platten verschlüsselt hat.
Wenn der wird nicht explodieren, warum soll's der explodieren?
Wieso willst du verschlüsseln, hast du was zu verbergen?
Ja, meine Handteilsammlung muss versteckt werden.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, also warum ich meine Festplatten alle voll verschlüsseln, ist ganz einfach.
Du kannst also, du kannst eine Festplatte easy wegschmeißen.
Du musst dir keine Gedanken mehr machen, das Ding ist kaputt, das ist wie auch immer, du nimmst das Ding, schmeißt den Müll und niemand kann damit was anfangen.
Und ich finde jedes Nass sollte voll verschlüsseln sein.
Leute, Leute, SCSI oder SCSI?
Was meint ihr? Also ich persönlich bin ja für SCSI.
SCSI, was nutzt du zum verschlüsseln unter Windows?
Veracrypt, ansonsten kommt es halt aus Netzlaufwerk.
Scutzy.
Besonders gut, wenn du beschissenen Supportverträge beherrscht und deine kaputten Festplatten zurückschicken musst.
Ja, zum Beispiel. Also es ist einfach angenehmer, wenn die Festplatte voll verschlüsselt sind, weil du kannst sie nehmen und auf die Gas schmeißen und es juckt kein.
Also du musst dir keine Gedanken mehr drüber machen und es hat ja auch bei ordentlicher Hardware kaum Performance einbußen.
Was hältst du eigentlich von einem Mac?
Und hast du noch ein iPhone? Ich habe aktuell drei, vier iPhones hier.
Ein iPhone SE, ein iPhone 6, ein iPhone XR und ein iPhone 11.
Weirdchamp. Alter, ich wurde gefragt im Chat, jetzt weirdchamp mich nicht, Leute.
No weirdchamp, please.
Ja, schön. Bringt auf Raspberry Pi trotzdem nichts.
Ach die, ach die. Ach die Speck. Was, fängt er auch noch mal an?
Okay, hier geht's los.
So und bevor ich jetzt weiter weirdchamp werde, ich habe keines dieser iPhones, doch das iPhone SE habe ich selbst bezahlt, ansonsten keines davon.
Deswegen muss ich die auch wieder zurückgeben.
Ja.
Es ist weg.
Really fun.
Das ist, ich habe sie nicht geklaut, Leute. Das ist von da, wo ich arbeite, kriegen wir immer mal wieder neue Handys oder neue Smartphones.
Und ich weiß auch nicht, warum sie das XR jetzt gegen den 11 ausgetauscht haben, ehrlich gesagt.
Das war nämlich noch top in Ordnung, aber gut, ich werde mich nicht beschweren.
Es hat funktioniert, unglaublich.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ja, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt. Ich meine, es bringt halt nichts. Es ist cool, dass es auf Raspberry Pi geht, bringen tut das nicht wirklich was.
Was denkst du über Kabel-Internet? Ich bin über Kabel-Internet gerade im Internet.
Ja, zeig mal, wie schnell ist es?
Ja, okay, das ist schön, schön und gut, kriegst du ein Gigabit mit voll, das Problem ist, sobald du das Ding verschlüsselt hast und wenn du es über das Netzwerk machst,
brauchst du IO, Netzwerk, Raid-Gedöns, der Fileserver braucht CPU und wenn die Festplatte voll verschlüsselt ist, braucht das auch noch ordentlich CPU,
weil die sich ja gedacht haben bei diesem Raspberry Pi Group, wir kaufen die CPU ohne Krypto-Extensions, weil es hätte 5 Cent mehr gekostet.
Hast du dann am Ende irgendwie fast 60 MB die Sekunde oder so? Sackt halt.
Ja, spät.
faster than the pie can even dream of getting so with that in mind i wanted to
see if the pie could get a little bit faster if i put the cm6 nvme drives into
a raid zero array and it did not a huge difference but now large kamikaze
raid was about as fast as it could possibly be on the pie and 4k random
reads were a little bit faster to give a little more data i also compared rate
null ist jeder einzig sinnvolle rate modus speeds of the single cm6 against a
single kingston ssd einfach back up machen und a single old hp sass hard
drive to the surprise of nobody the super old nein leute macht es nicht
decimated in random performance even by a cheap consumer ssd but throughput
isn't the only consideration when it comes to storage enterprise drives
usually have better warranties better ability to handle massive read or write
optimized workloads and price types okay er hat teurer enterprise ssd
angeschlossen einem raspberry pi und die sind auch nicht wirklich viel
schneller als anderes zeug aber es wird bei exzellent gut dass wir das jetzt
wissen wer hätte das nur gedacht
nee das wie gesagt also rate null ist eigentlich sogar eines der
unsinnigsten geschichten die es gibt weil früher bei festplatten war rate
null noch sinnvoll wenn du wirklich mehr sequentielle übertragung also mehr mehr
bandbreite haben wollte es aber jetzt bei sata ssd oder bei ssd ist es sogar
eher kontraproduktiv mit dem rate zu machen weil der riesen vorteil von einem
rate ist ja eben dass also bei einem rate null dass du mehr bandbreite kriegst
also dass die datens datenübertragung schneller geht das ist aber kein
problem weil ssd so schnell sind dass du den vorteil nicht brauchst und der
größte vorteil von ssd ist die schnelle zugriffszeit und die machst du bei rate
null eher noch einen ticken langsamer als mit einer einzelnen ssd also rate
null ist eigentlich aktuell eines der sinnlosesten rate level überhaupt vor
allem mit ssd ist
hast du schon von den tags gehört die twitch einführen will ne oder vielleicht
doch weiß jetzt gerade nicht
was denkst du über die realistische gefahr von einem plek out und die vollen
für ati und berufe von ein was für ein ding du meinst dass das das das das
dass das der strom ausfällt
dann kaufen wir uns einfach von französischen atomkraftwerken strom
wo ist das problem oder von belgischen
das control alt feiltaste klappt nicht wenn man in einer vm ist
na guck mal ich bin in der vm süße ich bin in der vm jetzt zack klappt doch zack
zack zack ok ich höre auf dich zu debaten du musst noch vorher was
anderes machen dass es funktioniert du drückst einmal control alt und dann
drückst du das du musst control alt drücken vorher control alt gibt die vm
frei du drückst ich habe es absichtlich nicht erzählt
max hat die bait versucht gestartet ja du drückst control alt und dann
control windows das geht wenn man geübt ist relativ schnell
es gibt was text auf twitch was gibt dann text für racers krankheiten warum für
krankheiten von ks was hier was geht twitch meine krankheiten an gibt es da
auch gibt es auch boomer tech dann geschlecht und sechse ja gut das ist ja
mittlerweile schon standard das sind wir alle dabei muss ja alles so aber
diverse sein wisst ihr was ich bei dieser sache nicht so ganz verstehe ich
habe ja da überhaupt nichts dagegen ich verstehe plus immer die die bestrebung
mancher leute nicht dass alles der der restlichen welt mitteilen zu zum zum
müssen ja wenn man das will ist es okay es stört mich nicht aber ich hätte da
gar kein großartiges großartiges interesse dran ehrlich gesagt
also mein außer dass ich art schluss verwende das muss ich natürlich schon
der ganzen welt erzählen aber ich hätte ich ganz ehrlich ich hätte keinerlei
bedarf irgendwelche sexuellen oder oder anderen vorlieben der welt mitzuteilen
und schon gar nicht in meinen twitch techs
weiß ich nicht es gibt ja leute die stehen auf füße so und mal angenommen ich
würde jetzt auf füße stehen würde ich dann wirklich den twitch tech machen
wollen wo fuß fetisch drin steht weiß nicht
und es müssen jagen also man muss natürlich wird man nicht gezwungen das
zu machen aber nachdem es eingeführt wird scheint es ja einen gewissen bedarf
dafür zu geben dass der welt immer mitzuteilen
die viewer würden hochgehen soll ich mal ein titel schreiben fußfetisch streben
kein quatsch
habt ihr noch irgendwelche videovorschläge der youtube algorithmus ist
gerade ziemlich broken und zeigt mir nur irgendeinen miss den ich nicht brauche
es gibt es immer semper video neues nur mal ganz kurz proxmox juckt mich nicht
nur mal ganz kurz
hot tubes bekommen eine eigene kategorie das habe ich schon gesehen das hatten
wir vorher sogar auf wenn du nach tipps auskommst du per kulose alda
das hatten wir vorher schon offen
sag mal alter jetzt ist er ja nackisch mittlerweile
immer vorher noch was angehabt
ja und übrigens bei the way ich habe falls ihr es noch nicht wusstet ich habe
auch einen eigenen pool stream channel extra dafür gemacht also ist nicht von
mir den mod erstellt aber wenn ihr nichts zu tun habt und wenn ihr entspannte
sack wenn ihr entspannte programmier musik haben haben wollt oder was auch
immer dann könnt ihr wupp wupp wupp tube champ
aufmachen ok so entspannt ist es jetzt kann ich was ist das für musik alter
ist ja wirklich gut gatschi man müsste man müsste da auch noch musik
voten können drin das wäre richtig big brain entspannter als fach das ist der
kapit soundtrack verstehe er dann ergibt es in weil das gaming gaming
playlists drin was in forever workstation ist eine maus unsichtbar
ne das weiß ich nicht ich weiß ich kann mich noch daran erinnern dass man dual
monitor support irgendwo in vmw einschalten musste glaubte ich glaube
man musste irgendwo bei display ja hier genau muss man irgendwie einstellen wie
viel monitore man hat und die passende auflösung aber wenn du das gemacht
hast weil er dann die maus nicht sieht keine ahnung du denkst die katze ist auf
thumbnail was finden besser die aktuelle katze oder die die wir davor hatten
aber ich werde wahrscheinlich nächstes team dann mal wieder die alte machen
immer ein bisschen hin und her wechseln passt beides passt beides finde ich ganz
gut sowohl die als auch die chico chico haut schicko auf die nase wusste die
eigentlich dass wir den passendes emote haben wir haben katz fps als emote
wir waren aber nur mit ffz und oder bei den twitch tv und wir haben jetzt was
neues leute moment moment ich rief recht mal chat wir haben was neues guck mal wir
haben jetzt wuppe arrive probiert maus hier messen
wo war eifung lief den wupp lief wenn ich fast noch cooler weil dass ich dann
umdreht guck du musst die freche dann klappt es bei dir auch
wenn eins ab ausläuft ja keine ahnung ob das sehe ich auch nicht ich sehe nur
dass du dein twitch konto erstellt hast 2014 ja leute gibt es irgendwas gutes auf
auf youtube was wir gucken müssen irgendwas hier gibt es was gibt es bei
der games da neues zeigt mal her haben die irgendwas spannendes wurde die gte
gtx 1990 aus versehen geliegt ja wie wäre es wie wäre es wenn es mal über
proforce neue grafikkarten geliegt werden mit grafikkarten die man kaufen
kann
hier zeigt die ps5 was nextgen wirklich kann wisst ihr was das beste ist wenn man
wissen will was nextgen wirklich kann einfach sich einen ordentlichen pc holen
easy easy as fuck schon seit letzten fünf jahren nextgen gg
was macht eigentlich gerade moment gibt es eigentlich gerade wieder grafikkarten
ob keine grafikkarten verfügbar aber aber aber aktuelle reisen tp us gibt's
die fast guck mal wie cool der preisverlauf hier zu sehen ist amd hat
es geschafft dass die dinge halbwegs lieferbar sind wieder die fast uvp sind
die reisen dinger guck mal guck mal jetzt lohnt sich mal so richtig der
jahresverlauf zu haben
das kennst du amd.com
das ist richtig scheiße guck mal hier wie schön man den verlauf jetzt hier
sieht leider leider gibt es keinen eine grafikkarten
naja gut das funktioniert ja auch ein bisschen anders das ist der
durchschnittspreis von den sachen die er am tag gefunden hat was hier drinne
steht über alle shops also dann ist kein wunder dass es nicht nicht uvp ist
sondern bisschen mehr festplatten werden auch teurer ja weil es jetzt alle
anfangen schia zu farmen als kacknubs da sollen mich lieber grafikkarten kaufen
lassen anstatt krypto zeug zu farmen
schia bezahlt locker die miete ja und wenn ich dann und wenn ich dann ab
september mehr steuern bezahlen muss kann schon wieder keine grafikkarte
leisten das ist ein teufelskreis ja jetzt will ich die grafikkarte kaufen kann
ich nicht und dann habe ich zu wenig geld kann keine grafikkarte mehr kaufen
vorbei gibt es irgendwas youtube algorithmus jetzt zeigt mir doch mal
was spannendes ich habe diesmal gedacht ich mache nicht allzu viele videos
vorbereitet vorbereitungstechnisch auf weil der youtube algorithmus das letzte
mal immer noch irgendwelche sinnvolle dinge ausgespuckt hat aber gibt es ja
nicht wie gesagt das ist langweilig das lohnt sich nicht für den preis
schaust du mal grober welcher warten das noch mal von dem habe ich
definitiv schon mal sachen geguckt das war nicht der ist perfekt wie balance
das ist der andere bei der preis jam auf github nein dann gucken wir jetzt doch
battlefield 4 top plays gibt es ja nichts anderes mehr hat er vielleicht
battlefield 3 top plays hochgeladen keck wait ne hat er nicht gut dann muss wir
jetzt eine runde battlefield 4 gucken easy und ich hoffe dass infanterie plays drin
sind wenn der kelp wieder nur komische heli und flugzeug plays hat dann mache
ich nicht schaue mal bei lost rein macht der lost macht der lost pool stream oder
was
noch gar nicht und
oder was meinste auf youtube ja der hat ein paar battlefield videos
hochgeladen letzter zeit das habe ich gesehen da war jetzt aber nichts dabei
was man jetzt schon was man jetzt schon wissen
nichts neues da kommt jetzt eine runde battlefield uns bleibt nichts anderes
übrig es sei denn ihr habt noch gute video idee und jetzt da kommen jetzt
battlefield top plays beim isi chinesen schreiber
oder ist nice alter ey der letzte war krass das war halt mega glück dass es
gehütet hat also dass der letzte geht das war mega glück und ihr wisst was ich
habe warum springt der typ da gerade runter warum springt springt da tut da
gerade runter kann das hat das versteht das jemand
warum springt der springt
auf player man weiß es nicht warum er runter springt aber es springt es springt
runter außerdem hartscope der hartscope loop
und ich sage ja am anfang dieser videos immer ich mache es absichtlich nicht
lauter weil er immer das gleiche sagt und dann sagt der chat ich sag auch immer das
gleiche aber der letzte war geil das war halt mega glück
schreckt eins muss ich ja sagen die diese bold action animation in battlefield
vier waren echt nice die also die fühlen sich immer die fühlen sich so so richtig
so richtig weich also das konnten sie echt und das sound war auch geil aber da
muss man ihnen mal sagen also ich mache da ist muss man echt mal da ist loben
sound technisch kriegen sie das immer saum ist also wirklich guten es gibt
glaube ich kein battlefield so ab ab ab bett company eins jetzt was was was
keinen geilen sound hatte mmo in java skript
die können wir uns gleich angucken
schreckt ja wohl vielleicht bist du auch älter geworden aber ja das problem
kenne ich die haben im battlefield vier schon einiges eingebaut dass es erst mal
sich anders spielt zum beispiel dass du nicht mehr so gut durch gegner durch
schließen kannst und sowas noch keinen hungern doch dann demnächst
ich habe noch ente mit erdnusssoße übrig vom china chinesen man ist das
playstation ist das playstation gameplay sieht so so so verschwommen aus
ja ja ist playstation gameplay erkennt sofort bewegungs unschärfer und
verschwommen muss playstation gameplay sein mission when the game first launched
one of the most epic ways to take down an enemy jet
und jetzt bitte jetzt das ding da drauf fallen lassen
boah ok das ist cool
drei drei drei was macht er
das teleskop ist eingeschützt ja ich weiß
und es sah fast fast ein bisschen so aus wie den battlefield
ist es eine nacht map oder hat er kell einfach zu stark komprimiert oder ist
es revolution
das ist das feier das ist der firestorm remake
leute wenn es noch mehr flugzeug clips gibt so geil die dinger sind aber ich
habe mich da mittlerweile schon echt satt dran gesehen aber das ist halt
krass dieses aussteigen wieder einsteigen das ist schon wirklich huge
was das das play aber trotzdem ich habe mich schon so satt gesehen an diesen an
diesen clips ich mag am liebsten einfach nur krasses
infanterie gebäsche beste weil das schon heftig ist also dreimal rausspringen
wieder in chat rein und killen das ist schon wirklich heftig
in i presume it was a friend of his who's playing it was set up
so im play on the enemy team das war set up you just can't switch but
unfortunately his friend biel managed to smore him as he was parachuting really
really rare to see as the title of this video suggests we're gonna be seeing
one man army clip and this one from dusty is exactly that it's slightly longer
a couple of minutes in total oh der kriegt flame nachrichten danach fucking shotgun
und dann wird die mutter beleidigt
play like this on nanja strike before using moment ich dachte es ist perry
still storm ist es aber gar nicht was ist das für eine map dlc mappe in the
medic class trying his best to get onto that objective eventually makes it work
and what's a street in the process
shotguns waren schon heftig in dem game oder auch in bf3 slug ammo über die halb
map so nicht normale
zwar was es für damage macht
aber der wurde geflammt der wurde garantiert geflammt richtig so shotgun
shotgun leute werden immer krass geflammt letztens wir haben doch
gestern bf3 gespielt ein bisschen habt ihr da gesehen wie krass die wieder im
chat abgegangen sind ich meine das ist ein game von 2011 oder so und die flame
zehn jahre später immer noch rum in dem chat als geht es irgendwie um die esl
meister schafft so
der stirbt an der kranne nicht der stirbt an der granate und weil man halt
sagen muss die lassen sich auch schon echt heftig weg passion von ihm mit der
shotgun
bieb bieb bieb bärm jetzt er tot der hat aber was hatten jetzt gekillt 20
gegner aus geht noch weiter es geht noch weiter
das war nicht schon vor dem weg 20 gegner das spiel nur wenige casuals das
Das stimmt, aber man kann auch einfach die Klappe halten und spielen.
Zumal der Typ, der rumgeflamt hat, derjenige war, der irgendwie 3-15 hatte oder so.
Fucking useless team und so.
Ich hab vergessen, wie er heißt, aber der ging voll ab gestern.
Trash cancer team und sowas.
Der hat übrigens rumgeflamt.
Die Leute, die schon in Battlefield über ihr Team flamen,
die sollen mal Overwatch ranked spielen, Alter.
Was? Nein, nicht Giraffe.
Giraffe hat nicht Giraffe mitgespielt, Giraffe hat nicht geflamt.
In Overwatch gibt es keine Stats, weil die damit verhindern wollen, dass geflamt wird.
Aber ich finde nicht, dass es das verhindern. Die Leute flamen auch so.
Oh nee, Metro, wer hätte das gedacht?
Aber das ist Battlefield 4 Metro, stimmt.
Da gibt es ja diesen Gang, den gibt es ja in Battlefield 3 nicht.
Sag mal, ich muss jetzt mal einen richtig low brain YouTube Comment nachmachen.
Der Spieler sagt, wie dunkel soll dein Spiel sein? Antwort Ja.
Das wäre so ein typisches dummes YouTube Comment, ja? Ja.
Aber der hat sich auch gedacht hier, bloß nicht zu hell machen, das Game.
Oh, wie sie sich sprähen lassen.
Moment, Moment, in Battlefield, Moment, man konnte hier hoch in Battlefield.
Ach nee, da gab es ja noch einen zweiten Ausgang. Jetzt, ja.
Niemand. Er, das Game muss dunkler sein. Genauso in Combat Mart.
Alter, lassen sie sich wegsprähen, wir haben weggespasst, Alter.
Sag mal, sind die AFK?
Was ist denn mit den Gegnern los?
Sind das Bots? Richtig echte Bots?
What? Paid. Die haben ja gar nichts mitgekriegt.
AK12, das war die Startwaffe, ne?
AK12, kam die im Jahr 2012 raus?
Wie wäre es mal mit einem Battlefield 3 Stream? Hab ich doch gestern gemacht.
Oh, wegsprähen. Gestern, ja, gestern. Aber nur kurz, glaube nur eineinhalb Stunden oder so.
Und davon wurden wir eine halbe Stunde spawn-raped.
Ein Battlefield 4 musstest du schon anders schießen als in BF3.
Locker, was sonst? Resi den Locker.
Alter, die lassen sich wieder erschrecken, ey. In den Fuß geschossen, bam.
Guck, das ist ein bisschen das, das ist das mein Problem, was ich schon immer mit Battlefield-Shotguns hatte.
Die sind übelst krass, aber manchmal hitten sie einfach nicht, obwohl sie hätten hitten sollen.
Hast du für deine Heizung ein Dashboard?
Gute Frage. Ich glaube, sowas sollte ich mal machen.
Also ich hab noch kein Heizungs-Dashboard, aber gut, dass du mich auf die Idee bringst.
Ich glaube, ich mach mal einen Heizungs-Dashboard und zeig euch das nächste Stream.
MP16-Beste.
Was bescheuertes Commentary von dem Kell, Alter.
Enemys don't have a chance, don't stand a chance when he have them in his crosshair. Ja, ach, wie. Poggers.
Sag mal, sind die Clips alle heute außergewöhnlich dunkel oder ist mein Monitor kaputt?
Du hast dir einen Mac-Mini-Server gekauft, weil da ganz gut ESXi drauflaufen soll. Was kannst du so für Heimserver empfehlen?
Einen billigen Low-Power Intel x86. Also Low-Power und niedriger Stromverbrauch, niedriger Eidl-Stromverbrauch.
x86 Intel. Low-Price, Low-Power. Die Dinger mit Mainboard-Unternehmen.
Und CPU für 80 Euro. Mit aufgelöteter CPU. Die sind ganz gut. Jetzt nicht für Massive-Load, aber Preis-Leistung sind die top.
Ja, gut. Nice. So, mal gucken, ob er jetzt einen Battlefield-3-Top-Play hochgeladen hat.
Post-Champ, Post-Champ. Nein, hat er nicht. So, was sollte ich jetzt noch gucken? Irgendeiner hat was gepostet. Das hier.
Oh, das ist ja Huge Sleep. Residenz-Lieber.
Das kann ich mir zum Einschlafen anhören.
Boah, da schlaf ich ein bei. Das geht echt nicht. Ich scroll mal kurz vor. Ich scroll mal kurz vor, was da rauskommt.
Okay, er will ein MMO programmieren in Backend-Technik. Wobei, ganz streng genommen, brauchst du noch nicht mal ein Backend. Du könntest sicherlich irgendwelche P2P-Dinger machen, aber schön ist es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Also einen Server wirst du wahrscheinlich brauchen. Okay, er hat einen Node-Server laufen, alles klar. Oh ja, Massive-Graphics, Alter.
Ich meine, aber immerhin, es ist doch heute schon mal cool, dass man mit ein paar Handgriffen sogenannt den JavaScript im Browser laufen lassen kann, oder?
Brainfuck-Video. Oh, nee. Okay, ich scroll mal ein bisschen weiter vor. Oh, Massive-Chat. Ich will mal gucken, wie es dann später aussieht.
Hey, es sieht ja fast schon aus wie Crunker I.O. Oder ehrlich gesagt, es sieht aus wie...
Irgendwie einer, der sich so nen... Kennt ihr noch diese alten, diese Baukasten-Dinger, die es früher gab? Die erstellen da ein eigenes Game, wo du dann so drei Sachen drin reinfühlst? So sieht das ein bisschen aus.
Es gab ja früher viele Games, die haben Level-Editor und sowas mitgeliefert, und man meint, du konntest da halt nach fünf Minuten sowas hier machen. Spiel mal Crunker. Mach ich ab und zu mal, aber so super zum Zugucken ist das nicht.
Aber das Coole ist, dass du sowas easy in JavaScript machen kannst. Es sieht aus wie Mobile-Game, ja.
Es ist halt absolut cheat-anfällig, so zu machen, aber gut, was willst du machen?
Okay, ich will einfach nur mal so gucken, was am Ende rauskommt. Aber immerhin.
Aber immerhin. Okay, so kommt er als... Das kommt er als raus, okay.
Aber das Coole ist, dass du sowas heute im Browser laufen lassen kannst. Das muss man auch echt mal hervorheben. Also gerade 3D im Browser, da ist schon wirklich viel passiert die letzten Jahre über.
So, was soll ich jetzt noch gucken? Brainfuck. Ja, Brainfuck ist eine tolle Programmiersprache.
Die besteht, glaube ich, aus Plus und Minus und Sternchen.
Wieso ist das Anti-Cheat in Overwatch so viel besser als in Battlefield, also aus technischer Sicht?
Wahrscheinlich weil Battlefield Anti-Cheat uralt ist im Kern und weil Blizzard viel Geld und Zeit und Kirnschmalz reinsteckt.
Ansonsten keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, wie beides intern funktioniert.
Ah, so Leute, ich hab Mist erzählt. Es ist tatsächlich mehr Zeichen in Brainfuck als Plus und Minus und Sternchen.
Es ist gar kein Sternchen, es ist Plus, Klammer auf, Klammer zu, Spitzeklammer auf, zu, Plus, Minus, Punkt und Semikolon. Ja, beste Programmiersprache überhaupt.
Also, ich würde sagen, wir sollten unbedingt mal Brainfuck programmieren in einem Stream.
Das ist fast so gut wie C++. Oder vielleicht sogar besser als C++, weil C++ sind für uns ja eigentlich so ziemlich die schlechteste Sprache die es gibt.
Moment, wenn B66 hat, dann hat ja C67, D68 und E69.
Das heißt E ist 69, das wusste ich noch gar nicht. Das E quasi in ASCII ist 69.
Und E ist 1 vor F, so langsam aber sicher wird mir alles klar.
Ich glaube, jetzt habe ich zum ersten Mal verstanden, wie die Welt funktioniert.
Es gibt im Prinzip nur E und F. Jetzt verstehe ich es. F ist RIP und E ist 69, also ist E quasi Geburt und F Sterben.
Okay, die Welt ist komplett, jetzt habe ich es verstanden. Und alles in ASCII-Code.
Was passiert da eigentlich gerade?
Das Ding heißt ja nicht umsonst Brainfuck.
Aber guter Code braucht keine Kommentare, das stimmt. Selbsterklärend.
Warum ist da oben eigentlich so ein weißer Strich immer im Video?
Gibt es irgendwelche ernsten Sachen, die in Brainfuck programmiert sind?
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Ich meine, du hast ja keine Möglichkeit, irgendwie Dateien einzulesen, zu schreiben, zu sonst was, aber...
Ich meine, wenn es das gehen würde, gibt es bestimmt Leute, die würden Sachen in Brainfuck programmieren.
Ich glaube Office 365 kann... Alter, das übertreibt man nicht. Office 365 vielleicht.
Wobei Office 365 ja nicht Office 365 heißt, sondern Microsoft 365.
Microsoft hat sich ja gedacht, Office 365 ist zu bekannt mittlerweile, deswegen heißt es jetzt Microsoft 365.
Und wahrscheinlich heißt es nächstes Jahr, wenn sich die Leute an Microsoft 365 gewöhnt haben, dann wieder ganz anders.
Microsoft, dann heißt es wieder Office 366 oder so. Da blickst du dir bei Microsoft der Ener durch.
Es gibt echt nichts, was mir hier empfohlen wird, was taugt noch.
Dann würde ich sagen, Leute, wir machen jetzt folgendes. Ich gehe jetzt essen und danach muss ich ein Video aufnehmen.
Wird Zeit. Wird...
Ah, Fressoren, genau.
So, soll ich jetzt den HotTube Stream hosten?
Soll ich jetzt den HotTube Champ hosten?
Ok, wir hosten den HotTube Champ. Host, ups.
Also, bis dann, macht's gut, see you.